there's no time o clock
[Music]
okay people we're back got Pookie with
us she's right there next thing you know
she's gonna stand up put her ass in the
camera I'm just trying to keep her calm
it's okay you can stay there just watch
the show today's gonna be a good night
because Ginny dug up a couple
poltergeist cases these are classic
poltergeist cases right not during I'm
talking about hauntings or ghosts we're
talking about yeah these are both kind
of like poltergeist cases some people
call them hauntings I guess but they you
know pretty much have the trappings of
life of the poltergeist which is our spk
recurrent spontaneous psychokinesis
usually usually involved kids going
through puberty of course you know if
you're regular listener you know my
history and art history with poltergeist
Jane wrote a book about poultra the
poltergeist phenomena you know two of
them did you know you wrote one that was
like a compilation compilation the cases
are both in there so okay and then
another one she wrote was about what
happened to me and my family back when I
was a kid yeah and of course Jenny's
she's talked about some of the stuff she
saw you know in recent years around me
when when poltergeist starts kicking off
you know that's it sounds [ __ ] crazy
I wouldn't believe it unless I saw it
but you know it's a recurrent phenomenon
that I've seen it was funny is like the
old guys the old pair of psychologists
you know that talked about this I don't
know if they know I exist or not but
those [ __ ] don't contact me they're
talking about how they're about how rare
this phenomenon is and not a single one
of us [ __ ] called me yeah except
Steve Steve Mehra but I called him ya
know I didn't call him but you're not
contacted him but anyway before we get
into the show JD's got some some shout
outs of stuff we got all
yeah I mean I did want to say like
before we get into that that you know
we've been doing like a lot of true
crime shows and that's you know mostly
because that's you know my main topic of
interest and also that's what I get the
99% of the requests for is true crime
topics but somebody said oh I missed you
know all your paranormal shows and gave
me like a recommendation for a
poltergeist case that I had actually
written about before my book and I
figured well why not it's like it seems
like it's seems like good to do
something kind of fun and light-hearted
because you have so many like depressing
topics yeah I'm in that
yeah I'm using weeks I miss paranormal
too because you know I mean true crime
can get on you after a while
I don't put for me poltergeist is kind
of light hop light-hearted in a way but
you know it might be creepy for you guys
it is creepy when you see it you know
maybe it's a show goes on all might
chime in you know what it's like to see
something or me what happened to me
depends on I don't even know what cases
they are Jimmy can just pull these out
but I don't say pull her out of her ass
but she just pull them out what are
these J what cases we're doing the black
monk of Pontiff oh okay I know that one
which you know that was the one that was
requested and I said I worry about that
one and and then I figured well I didn't
know if that would take up like a whole
show I think that was more of a haunting
but go ahead but uh so then I decided to
do the brother dolly case which happened
in Wales which one was that I'm not sure
like both of these cases I'm not sure
how much of the [ __ ] I believe okay but
um you know we'll see well there have
been several good ones over the years
you know in in in the UK first one would
have been yeah these are both in the UK
yeah first one would have course been
[ __ ] what's in it and Enfield haunting
right [ __ ] I got that book over here
that's more like what I saw and what my
family saw but that's probably the best
most documented case newspaper people
and cops saw that one but it was funny
nobody wants to talk about that [ __ ]
anymore they kind of aged out over time
I think it's weird because for a while
I mean I thought even in the UK I
thought that Enfield was kind of the
best known case and for a while I
thought it was one of the best known
British cases particularly after the
conjuring two came out which was kind of
based on it but when I was looking into
like refreshing my memory about the
black monk of Pontefract case it seems
that that has become more famous than
Enfield weird
I found [ __ ] tons of like paranormal
investigation shows ghost hunter YouTube
channel [ __ ] like that going to this
house because it's still there and you
can go in there and like investigate it
and I watched like a whole bunch of
videos of people that did just that and
so I do feel like it's become like a lot
more famous I guess when I was writing
about it for my book which was you know
several years ago now I didn't get the
feeling I mean I got the feeling that it
was like one of the better-known cases
in the UK but I didn't feel like it was
like nowadays that it was this really
big famous case because it happened in
the 60s but apparently I was wrong about
that because there's [ __ ] tons of like
ghost hunter ghost hunting teams that
have been there like TV shows and [ __ ]
like that over there so it's kind of
like a big [ __ ] deal okay the brother
dolly case not so much it seemed like
there was kind of um you know kind of a
big you know brouhaha about it when it
happened like in the 2000s but then it
kind of like I get because I think it
faded away like in 2001 and then I think
after that it didn't really like get a
lot of media anymore maybe because it's
not because it largely wasn't malevolent
or people didn't get the feeling that
was malevolent I feel like the blackmont
case people like that because you know
it's known as like one of the most
violent poltergeist cases in Europe it's
like you know we you know some people
actually got like heard or like got
thrown around and then there was that
creepy like apparition that some people
said that they saw so it was a lot
creepier whereas the brother dolly one
was more you know I it was weirder for
sure but it you didn't get the sense
that there was like any like a
malevolent presence it almost seemed
like a playful or like a mmm like a
friendly presence maybe or whatever
as far as the UK stuff goes
based on everything I've seen so far I'd
have to give it to the Enfield haunting
because it well they call it a haunting
it was a poltergeist which there is a
difference and we're gonna get into that
product yeah and filled it matches up
perfectly with what I saw and I'm only
really talking about the reliable
witnesses because in the Enfield case
there were some witnesses that were
unreliable that made some things up yeah
but what the cops saw with the newspaper
people when newspaper reporters saw what
guy Playfair saw and what was the name
of the the guy yeah more so what Moore
saw that's basically what I saw
it's that same phenomena and Janet Janet
is a good reliable witness to that some
of these people who are you know
standing out on the street saying that
they saw her levitating and floating
around you know in front of the damn
wind yeah I wouldn't I wouldn't put much
into that there well and it's hard to
see things from the street up in a
window anyway yeah well and then also
some people said that they saw you know
male figure a male figure in another
apartment you know I mean next to it
yeah I kind of doubt that
I saw apparitions but they weren't
humanoid a person's just kind of like a
bluish haze
it's an abortion a lot of the cases that
I wrote about cuz like in my book I did
have a section where you know people had
seen it was like a poltergeist type [ __ ]
was happening but then like people said
that they saw apparitions most of them
were not humanoid yeah the black monk is
an exception but that didn't start out
like that that [ __ ] didn't happen until
later on you know what I got ideally I
gotta say this though experiencing
poltergeist phenomena especially over a
period of time can scare the [ __ ]
[ __ ] out of you you might fool yourself
into thinking that you saw humanoid
apparition I'm gonna grant that does
just because you saw you were so scared
you saw he went oh an apparition doesn't
mean that it was there right and that
somebody else that was there would have
seen that like my aunt Lois remember
seeing thing
that I know didn't happen yeah but she
was so scared she she connected dots
that weren't there
yeah and that's a very common like you
know we found a wax scribbling on a
window that said go it came from a damn
brought Brad twist tied so to put go
there I showed it to them louis
remembers seeing the damn wax paper
right it that didn't happen
yeah red and i found it and it was
already there and yeah and and the twist
i was under it was on the floor in front
of it but she's in her seventies now and
and memory has a weird way of playing
tricks on you I mean that's yeah before
red died you remember I've talked to him
over the phone and he could remember
certain things that happened that I
forgot all about big stuff yeah like
what happened to the hot wheel cars and
you know well yeah I couldn't believe
that he had that you would forgot I
forgot about that that's why I liked
before before I wrote the book we
definitely like had several long like
conversation with all of them like and
for the phone and the knife phenomenon
of it throwing that knife and almost hit
in the damn sliding glass glass door and
then falling I forgotten about that yeah
he reminded me of that I mean oh yeah
that's right I forgot about that one
yeah and you would think that a big big
event like that that that would be but
so much [ __ ] so much [ __ ] happened right
and you even admitted that to me like
before I talk to them you said look it's
like I know I can't remember every
single thing to happen because [ __ ] was
happening all the time yeah every few
minutes when it was when it was really
ramped up every few minutes as an object
would move and it would mysteriously
move and a lot of times it was moving in
other rooms where nobody was in there
you hear disturbances and stuff moving
at the time we thought it was a [ __ ]
ghost that was their only explanation
for it but as the years went on the more
I knew understood the phenomenon the
more I kinda like started hearing you
know educated guys come up with some
damn theories in terms of you don't I
mean like who's that who's the
anesthesiologist that came up yeah
Hameroff Stuart Hameroff and he's
friends with big
[ __ ] physicists and stuff there's
another way this phenomena could happen
and that's and I think it's I think
Hameroff skyrise well as I said if this
stuff does happen the way people have
reported it and I you know said this in
my book as well you know it if that is
the case then I don't think it's dead
people doing stuff no I think it's some
kind of well you know we don't
understand yet Jenny's seen it it's
weird innit
it is weird it wasn't like I was glad
that I saw it it didn't really freak me
out
yeah you know I mean we told the story a
million times Jenny saw the remote fly
off a [ __ ] table yeah well what I
didn't just a bunch of people that were
there and when it hit the ground it
sounded like a damn ton of bricks boom
and it didn't bounce that was weird and
it's plastic it's fantastic it's a
regular TV role control and I was kind
of zoning out and when I stood up to
look at it I looked down at my feet and
there was a stack of coins and I haven't
touched any coins in a long time don't
use cash around here the coins came from
kind of like a semi abandoned little box
that I had on the nightstand that's what
it came from that what that was weird
what a little stack of coins about that
I there's that's like nickels and
pennies and [ __ ] yeah right yeah and
when it when's the last time we've ever
[ __ ] with any coins in this house
everything's cards last time we were at
Aldi but that was at one quarter that
was in my car yeah yeah but not mad yeah
not in the house now and you know we
don't deal with cash we have to deal
with cash in years that was weird and
then things like doors not people
ringing the doorbell night and there's
nobody there
garage door open and doors that were
locked finding them open and they're
still locked like with the deadbolt and
that one I think that freaked me out the
most I think because I mean the [ __ ]
that happened in our house like with the
statues like oh yeah yeah I wasn't here
the rowlandm like I wasn't here for that
I was at work you just told me about it
later
yeah um but the [ __ ] with the door the
back patio door um that weirded me out
the most because I I was the first one
to see that because I just got up and I
was going to work and I looked out and
I'm like that [ __ ] door is wide
open
yeah it was out and we never opened that
door yeah and even like I don't think
we've maybe open that door two times the
whole eight or nine years we've lived
there yeah and that and that and our cat
Beijing was sitting there just and she
wasn't looking at it like like why is
that open why is that open even she
knows yeah and it wouldn't and hadn't
been open for long because it wasn't
even hot in here you know in places
air-conditioned yeah
so it wasn't it hadn't been open along I
think I left for work at like it might
have been quarter to 8:00 in the morning
so I don't know how long had it been
open at that point but it's like it was
wide open and then what else what else
that weird that it happened oh I walked
towards the damn DVD player with a DVD
in my hand and the tray opened up that
wasn't that was one the damn little
plastic shot glass that I was measuring
eliquid in out of the corner of my eye I
was weird I was playing a video game it
fell through a bookcase that I had it
fell from one of the top shelves to the
bottom shelves but there's no way it
could have fell like the street yeah it
went straight down because it would have
to come out and then go back in I saw it
on the core Mirage Gohan and then when
it hit on the bottom it hit and it
vibrated it was great and I paused the
game and looked at it and it was weird
because there near it is is the dam at
the time it was those blinds that you
have for a sliding glass door they all
kind of moved or got compressed against
the glass like a wind blew on them but I
didn't feel any wind that was some weird
[ __ ] it happened fast yeah but since I
had seen that kind of stuff before I I
don't get I don't get I don't let myself
get run a rope will cut run away with it
because it's easy to get freaked out and
once it starts free you start freaking
out it starts ramping up start
snowballing
like when the remote flew off jen-jen
and Demetri saw it and they saw it hit
and I stood up and my hair started to
stand up on the back of my head and my
neck yeah I'm getting freaked out
talking about it right now yeah do you
hear my voice
yeah Demetri said do it again Tom do it
do it again and [ __ ] it started to
run away with me and I had to back off
with it and they knew you were like
nothing because I'm afraid to be
Island well yeah because like I said and
I think we said this on one of the side
track shows it's that you don't know I
mean you know it's you it's part of your
unconscious though you don't know what
it's gonna do yeah it's the you that
controls all them characters in your
dreams and yes and that version of you
sometimes in your dreams attacks you
because I've been attacked by bears I've
been tagged by people in my dream yeah
he's always fighting so I'm fighting
people so I'm always afraid that if that
[ __ ] [ __ ] starts kicking out the
unconscious mind it might have turn on
me to tag me or somebody else that's
what I got and I think I made a joke
about it Steve that night I was like
yeah don't like encourage that because
he won't get mad at me one day like a
brick come flood it like me hit me in
the [ __ ] hat there isn't just one you
you're you're waking consciousness is
only one one routine run and there are
other versions of you in there oh I feel
that someday yeah they're not all good
all kind of little yeah quack and
[ __ ] when it cut people's court from
callosum zap art you know so the right
hemisphere and the left hemisphere can't
communicate with each other and all
kinds of weird [ __ ] happens because you
don't agree with yourself most of the
time yeah you're in there fighting
yourself yeah now people don't realize
it well that's what I mean the front of
your brain is like your executive
function that's kind of like the boss
that's being like all right we're doing
this he like listens to everybody's
little opinions I guess yeah like in the
back I don't know Mitty I don't think
it's any kind of energy or any kind of
power or anything it's some kind of an
emergent property having to do with
altered states of consciousness we don't
really know what consciousness is in
some way consciousness can somehow
change the state of matter in the same
way they have the Heisenberg uncertainty
principle where an object can be in one
place or the other depending on whether
or not you're looking at it or not which
that's some weird [ __ ] that's all
quantum physics well nothing really I
mean there are some types of particles
they don't have a position until you
mean yeah until you measure the position
well whatever it is you need
consciousness to [ __ ] find position
all right it's kind of like do you hear
a tree if it falls in the [ __ ]
and nobody's there you know it's that
kind of thing somehow altered states of
consciousness can somehow change the
state of matter I don't know how I don't
understand it yeah
nobody does well ya know anybody that
says that they do is lying yeah and if
you have some kind of if you're in some
kind of weird emotional state objects
might move and no no energy involved
imagine if we can harness that [ __ ]
nothing that's how UFOs fly yeah it's
true cheating see that's kind of
something that I mean what would happen
if just like in five years we actually
figured that out right you would not be
able to harness that kind of [ __ ] I mean
everything would completely completely
well what you're talking what Frank
Hubert was predicted would have come
true where you'd be able to have like
guild steersman taken dem [ __ ]
mind-altering drugs to allow space
travel because you could bend space by
thinking about it in a weird way yeah
you could travel without moving you just
make an object appear here and then
there that's how they were doing it in
dune B handy-dandy yeah somehow
consciousness can alter matter which is
not quite the same as mind over matter
but in the way it is I guess yeah
because it didn't require I like you've
seen it happen did it look like I was
exerting any kind of force or any no
you're just like spaced out spaced out
you're just like laid on the couch good
yeah so you can't try to do it it's just
something that happens yeah you have to
you you always say that you can't like
try to make it happy up till allow it
you have to kind of allow it to happen
you kinda have to be mindless yeah weird
all right so before we get into talking
about these two cases I have a whole
bunch of shoutouts you guys all right
now some of these I've done shoutouts on
the side track shows but I know not
everybody watches those every day so I
kind of like to put them all together
like on the big yeah I don't know why
nobody watches them cuz flick and they
seem to be our most popular [ __ ]
everybody loves that [ __ ] like I said we
only just do those like for the fans
mostly and I just feel like everybody
else is traffic yeah yeah I mean no
one's really gonna find them if they're
not looking for a specific topic that we
talked about that's true
so you don't you know what I mean so
it's not like anyone's gonna find it in
the search or anything but yeah so um
want to give another thanks to Dominic
never sending us the movies one of which
we've already reviewed Sophie sent us a
bunch of pop figures yeah it was we did
those on the side track show like we
said with I got all the members of Duran
Duran all five of the original members I
got two 80s from Iron Maiden in Billy
Idol's that's right there's right back
there yeah I know I just like I kind of
want to take him out of the box with it
I kind of don't yeah you kind of want to
keep me in the box for collector
purposes now the boxes are cool they got
adventures on I do I have one of Darrell
from walking dead but I took him out of
the box yeah we lost the box and then he
faded also another thanks to Joseph for
sending us a whole [ __ ] ton of movies
including Dolomites yeah Beetlejuice yes
you gave it to Dennis some games and
some CDs and just all kind of fun [ __ ]
there was like two little care packages
that was awesome yeah Dolomites was
awesome it was what was the name of it
it said uh what was the name of the doll
of my movie just dolomite yeah okay I
thought it had like a sub a different
title now okay now the second one's
called the human tornado yeah even
tornadoes yeah that's like I said we've
rewatched Dolomites as my call wasn't we
DP extreme PD wheat straw the devil's
son-in-law yes I think it's like an
exorcist movie in it that's yeah yeah
that's not it's on to beer it was last
time I checked ok guys see so some of
those other ones might be on there too
but I wanna see all his shoes [ __ ]
hilarious
it was also we have two new patrons
James
so Haven and stop prop so thank you very
much also we got to PayPal donations
today okay one from Melanie who sends
this one like a whole like all the time
so thank you very much for that and
one's from D Newton from the UK because
it was in power
sterling oh man got that special money
that's the pretty Spanish a medal it's a
whole pound of [ __ ] silver yeah what
it sounds like my dad used to have like
a bunch of silver like ingots and he's
like you know to me are you selling him
like when silver was particularly they
were out of grenadine syrup today
because uh you know for whatever reason
it was it's weird because we went to the
liquor store next to the Publix and then
we went to the big store and they were
out and they were all so out of breath
so I had to make my own grenadine syrup
made it out and nothing else was out
pomegranate seeds just Kennedy yeah
pomegranate seeds put them up in sugar
and water with a little bit of vanilla
and a little bit of orange and that's my
[ __ ] pomegranate and it's good that's
really good
well it tastes just like regular better
I mean I think it's better than great
yeah it doesn't quite the color isn't
quite good as the artificial [ __ ] you
know what I mean well yeah but that's
because they use like yeah I'm just I'm
mystified like why they why grenadine
was the only thing that they didn't have
people drinking their asses off I mean
everything else yeah but you think if
everybody was drinking their asses off
which they were and who can blame them
but why is grenadine the only thing
that's got that's gone because it's so
common I mean it's caught very common
you know what I mean into drink so you
know I mean [ __ ] man I get a whole big
thing of vodka I got some new things
eggs so I could make some [ __ ] yeah
Bloody Marys I'm gonna get off into
making my own [ __ ] Serbs though now
that I found that group irresolute yeah
before um before like all the bars
closed down we were talking to UM yeah
talking I think we're talking to Dan or
talking to somebody at a tie bar and he
was talking about making all he said all
different types of services don't buy
that grenadine yeah I said really you
guys yeah you can make that at home for
nothing make a whole bunch of it and I
remembered that when he when I went to
grocery store and he said that you know
that they were out yeah it was
pomegranate seeds yeah
so I found it wait
pomegranate juice - yes I use
pomegranate seeds and a couple of
cranberries frozen cranberries I had in
the freezer yeah to make it a little try
to make a little more red it's good yeah
it worked yeah vanilla and a little bit
of orange juice in it see where there's
a little there's a way there's a will
I'm gonna keep me from drinking goddamn
it they called for orange peel but I
didn't have it yeah we come on now we
got lemon juice mm-hmm I don't think we
have any lemons lemons but there's a
bunch of other little syrups that you
can make a gun all that I got all those
berries in there yeah you should start
making some yeah make some [ __ ] drink
mixers man yeah a drink makes patron
yeah yeah all right people we haven't
even got the cases yet we're in trouble
he's gonna be yelling and like waving
his arms or I walk today we did a bunch
of exercise did a bunch of lifting and
[ __ ] I walked six miles today yeah I did
that's all right all right so you want
to start talking about this first case I
want to hear about this first case all
right this is the black mocha Pontefract
as I said this actually started in 1966
and like I said even though this one
happened a long time ago and Enfield was
more recent and there's like a big
Hollywood movie about it and stuff like
that it seems like this one has more
modern cachet I guess maybe it's because
you can actually go to the house cuz
here's the thing I guess the house has
been empty like no one's lived in it for
many years but I don't know if it's a
council house or if somebody owns it
because the next-door neighbor it's like
at the end it's a semi-detached so it's
like not like a row house but there's
like another house like attached to it
so the woman that lives in the attached
house whose name is Carol she has the
key to the house and she's apparently
allowed to let people in there so when
Ghost Hunters come you can come and just
like go knock on Carol's door and be
like hey can we do a ghost hunting
investigation over there and she'll give
you the keys and she'll let you stay
there overnight because a bunch of ghost
hunters have and also she will talk your
goddamn ear off so nobody actually lives
in the house nobody lives there anymore
now okay
I'm gonna just say off the top of my
head just doesn't sound like a
poltergeist sounds like more like a
haunting well it's because well I
haven't even got into the got it yet
I'm just saying that nowadays maybe
that's why you get so many shows and
stuff like that set and you know that
where they go to that house now because
it's easy to go to you know what I mean
there's somebody in there that will like
show you around and let you in and let
you stay there which makes a good show
and like I said it's this haunting kind
of got a reputation for being like the
most violent haunting in Europe so it
kind of has that mystique about it it's
hilarious because this woman that lives
next door I don't know how full of [ __ ]
she is I'm not really sure but um she
was in I guess she's from Yorkshire
maybe cuz she has a really really thick
accent and um so she comes over there
and she every single ghost hunting show
I saw that was like a uk-based team she
was just over there and she just like
told Evers like every single [ __ ] that
like happened to her in the house and
happened her her family members in the
house and all this other kind of stuff
and it's weird because I'm gonna say
right on the outset before I get into
the [ __ ] that have it in the 60s that
I'm sorry whenever she does whenever she
does like her pre thing interview and
she's letting to go sending teams in
there like small [ __ ] will happen in the
house like um you know like a marble
will go flying or they'll be like weird
noises or something but as soon as she
leaves nothing happens anymore I'm not
saying anything okay I'm just saying
that's interesting so do my house when
she's there yeah this way and now she
says it's because the poltergeist hates
her and doesn't like her in there okay
so now it's now you open it up a new
door now this is something that's been
reported over the years sometimes older
women Kennex can't look I think anybody
can actually be a poltergeist focus its
most likely it's more it's most likely
it's a kid going through puberty well
that was the case in the sixties when
they when these manifestations allegedly
first start it's been reported as
sometimes single lonely women can also
be good I have written about a few cases
whatever that yeah and
cuz I'm a I'm at the time it was in my
40s and a man in a relationship I would
be an outlier yeah and in terms of
poltergeist focus but Jenny knows more
about me than then you people are ever
gonna do outlier on a lot of [ __ ] when
you say Jenny yeah you definitely my
[ __ ] was normal no which to be a
statistical outlier I think on a lot of
things yeah when you say with life
history yeah yeah oh definitely yeah so
you know I mean don't you can't you
can't look at the poltergeist phenomena
and say it's only limited to kids that's
a stereotype I think it's the most
likely but adults can do this too I have
written like I said I have written about
a few cases where um I remember one
particular case I can't remember where
it happened or what exactly but it's in
my book somewhere but um where I believe
it was like three generations of women
like a grandmother a mother and the
daughter and [ __ ] started happening in
there and they thought when like the
investigators came they thought that the
grandmother was actually the focus
because [ __ ] just happened when she was
around and not so much when the kid was
around well he said the kid was probably
not the focus at all cuz [ __ ] didn't
happen when she was there when I was a
kid researching what had happened what
had happened in my family this is back
when I was like 15 16 17 we used to have
these things called books they don't
hardly have them anymore and I don't
know what happened to a lot of but they
had books about poltergeist phenomena
and one of the cases that I remembered
reading about a book that have now been
able to find on the internet anymore was
a case that happened in Tokugawa era
Japan where a young where silk sheets
and silk robes were being torn in half
and pots and pans were flying up in the
air and beating and being thrown through
the pit right
paper walls of a house whenever a young
servant girl Japanese servant girl was
around they didn't the the people didn't
know what to make of it but you see
you're not doing with the Western
civilization so you're not doing with
Christians they thought it might have
been evil spirits so they called in a
samurai
now samurai isn't always a [ __ ]
with a sword if you know anything a
samurai was any educated upperclassmen
most samurai never killed anybody didn't
they carried the sword but they were
scholars a lot of them during the
Tokugawa care a samurai came in who was
evidently a very good what they would
consider a scientist and an investigator
and he figured that he figured that it
was not evil spirits that it was this
girl because it happened around her and
that there may have been an imbalance of
her Chi yeah and he prescribed firing
her problem-solve which is weird when
you think about it when you think about
Chi Chi ended up coming into Western
culture in a movie called Star Wars so
you're kind of talking about the Sith
and the Jedi in a certain way you know I
mean a disturbed person might have some
weird phenomenon happen around them and
and George Lucas got this from writings
like this you know the meniscus the the
these ideas predates Star Wars but
that's kind of what we're talking about
yeah you know which I find that
fascinating and for a while I kind of
gave too much weight to Star Wars until
I realized and I saw the new ones then I
was like they're making this [ __ ] up but
[ __ ] George Lucas was making [ __ ] up
too but he was inspired by a lot of well
yeah he had ideas from like a lot Easter
yeah this is so a lot of what we're
talking about
Westerners see this through a Western
lens an Easterner would see this through
a totally different lens
janna is that what Westerner is gonna
see it with demons and
through religion and Easterner would see
it through the lens of Chi energy yeah
life force which is probably closer
which i think is closer to the truth
yeah there that's their explanation of
it I don't think no I don't think it is
either although I've had out-of-body
experiences and stuff which I've talked
about in other shows I do believe in an
afterlife even though I'm a myth assist
I don't believe in religions per se
those are just myths but they're based
on stuff that seems I saw stuff that was
like that and I think that's where they
got a lot of it but then of course you
give somebody an inch they want to take
a mile yeah you might have it you might
have a paranormal experience the next
thing you know you want to try to run
[ __ ] so you're gonna write a book to
help you run some [ __ ] that might be
part of with what you're seeing with
religion yeah but because you can't
really trust those stories that's of
course you know and usually it's about
you know authority and trying to change
it anyway I want to tell other people
what to try and tell other people what
to do and saying that like some big
imaginary like person in this guy is
gonna kick your ass ya know when I had
it when I had another body experience I
just felt liberation I didn't feel like
I you know there was kind of a life
review you know during that motorcycle
accident there was beings and I've
talked about that before beings that
know you and kind of like counselors but
I think they're a mixture of maybe
people you once knew or beings that you
once knew and then maybe like different
versions of yourself talking to you like
more ancient versions of yourself like a
what in some studies they would call the
Dame on the super you you know the
timeless version of you but it seemed
more like heaven and God and existence
were all the same thing it was just more
like a place kinda like the internet
yeah and it was responsive I'm going
whoo we're getting off to [ __ ] a subject
I'm sorry what's this we
well I understand usually usually when
people are listening to a show like this
they're also interested in in this in
subjects like this so I'm just trying to
I'm trying to make a most complete show
as possible yeah
and you know I've got some liquor in me
so I can my tongues loose normally I
don't talk like this well it's kind of
embarrassing
kind of embarrassing to talk about this
kind of [ __ ] to me sometimes but is it
really yeah it is it is but I know it's
true because I've seen it all though
it's hard to find out what true is
because true had has a lot to do with
your point of view in your mind state
you know mean but I know that
poltergeist phenomena is real I know
that out-of-body experiences and
near-death experiences are real I
believe what you see in them is is real
but it's given unto you in a way that
you want it to be in other words like
you know I mean you see the things that
you need to see in order for you to
process it it's interactive you know I
mean yeah like friends that if you're a
Hindu you might see Shiva you know if
you're a Muslim you might actually talk
to two Jabril or [ __ ] you know
Muhammad you know if you're Christian
you probably will see Jesus is that who
that really is or probably not but it's
gonna come to you in the form that you
can accept it yeah at least early on it
might evolve into something else later
what's your dad for a while you know I
mean it'll look like a reptilian no I
don't like lit lit it's kind of like
being in a universe of [ __ ] just
totally limitless and unbounded you know
what I mean and yeah there are no limits
at all you know that's what that's what
I remember it as being it was [ __ ]
weird but anyway glad it wasn't weird it
was actually very familiar when you get
there and very normal and it seemed very
right well you said it didn't frighten
me not at all not at all matter of fact
I didn't want to come back yeah yeah
which me that that makes sense yeah it
was so much better it was like being you
know yeah is it much better but you're
here to do certain
things to complete the tapestry of
creation and you're here to learn the
lessons that you have to learn all this
just [ __ ] temporary yeah but on the
other side is it's a singularity it's
[ __ ] awesome you'll see you'll see
Jenny Jenny was Jenny was like man I'd
like to see the poltergeist and I showed
it it came yeah it took a while because
like I said we talked about it you know
we were talking about your case for a
long time because we were working on the
book and we were talking to Lois and rad
about it and yeah thing so it's like for
months and months it's like all we
talked about because we're all working
on the book I started to get kind of
creeped out yeah well you said that that
sometimes you didn't you were like I
don't want to talk about it yeah I
started get kind of creeped out well it
was kind of like remember you said this
is you felt like someone's watching you
yeah you knows like that yeah I feel
like I'm watching like I'm being watched
yeah but I know it's like another
version of me I'm afraid of it a little
bit I don't have that sensation too much
I've had it a couple times like I said I
think the worst time I hadn't was at Big
Lots that time but I've had it I had it
at my grandmother's house one time to
when I was just like sitting at the
dining room this is the only time I ever
had that like in her house I didn't
think her house was on it or nothing but
and I lived there for quite a long time
but I was just sitting at the dining
room table one day and all of a sudden I
could have sworn that someone was
standing right behind me yeah and it has
wig me out and we'll cuz I because I
went like that was like what the [ __ ]
and it's like I did and it the creepy
thing was that my my grandfather's ashes
were in the cabinet behind there so I
don't know it's like it was really
really that feeling of having somebody
watching you over your shoulder yeah is
super intense in a good poltergeist yeah
well this was really in tonight I have
no - I would have bet a thousand dollars
that's all it was standing behind yeah
something was getting ready to happen
yeah
yeah I can't understand it but somebody
said I I don't have it very often I
think I've only had it like maybe twice
or three times somebody was there but
yeah it was like it was really weird
so so all this [ __ ] is also related
relating to dreaming true
I dreamed true a lot and sometimes in
the middle of a dream I feel like it I
could exit the dream and go into into an
astral version of Rio
that's another subject though but it but
the thing is is that you're your your
normal animal instincts tell you not to
do that because it's like it's cheating
yeah like you're not supposed to do it
because it's not time that's where
you're gonna go after you die
yeah you just wait yeah right you're
here to play this role now on this page
they don't want you getting off a stage
and taking breaks and cheating existence
isn't about this life so much it's about
learning from this life and the
limitations that you have in this life
you know it's like what you've watched
it's like you've chosen to watch this
movie yeah for what you can learn you
know main you don't want to walk out of
the movie or face like that that's a
good analogy yeah that is that's
actually a good way putting it good so
uh aside from this being like one of the
more violent poltergeist outbreaks
allegedly it was also one that very
weirdly and this doesn't happen in a lot
of these types of cases um your initial
manifestations when they happened you
know they happen for a little while and
then they stopped for like two years but
then they started up again two years
later and they were like worse you know
what I mean yeah which doesn't happen a
lot so the first time that this should
happen it was in 1966 now this is a
house it's a 30 East Drive in the town
of Pontefract like I said it's still
there you can go visit it the first
people that moved in there were the
Pritchard family this was Joe and Jean
Pritchard with a mom and dad they had a
fifteen-year-old son named Philip and a
twelve-year-old daughter named Diane it
was a good ages yeah to uh for something
like this to happen okay great so the
first things that happened um they moved
in I guess they had been there maybe for
a month or two like it didn't nothing
seemed completely weird or anything
September first
most of the families the mom and the dad
and the daughter had gone away like on
vacation they had gone to Devon or
something like to visit relatives so
Philip stayed in the house
and his maternal maternal grandmother
Sarah Scholes came over to the house to
watch him you know cuz he was 15 so I
guess they didn't really on his own for
however long they were gone so so so
he's out like messing around in the
neighborhood with his friends or
whatever his grandma is it home like
doing her knitting or whatever now
Philip comes home and the first thing
they notice was this really really cold
chilling wind blowing through the house
even though the day was quite hot it was
only the 1st of September so it was
still like you know I know it's England
so that kind of shakes out yeah that was
the first thing then as they were both
kind of sitting in the living room
chilling out they see this weird powder
they said it looked like chalk powder
you know what I mean like when you bang
erasers and stuff yeah they said it
looked like that but it looked like it
was coming out of midair and that it was
like falling on the furniture okay like
this kind of like thick like cloud of
white dust it sounds like poltergeist
already yeah and like laying on the you
know furniture so at this stage they're
both thinking I mean it wasn't scary
they were just like sitting there going
what the hell what the [ __ ] is that
stuff yeah
so they go across the street they had a
neighbor who was a friend of theirs
named Marie Kelly and they went over
there and said hey you know there's some
weird [ __ ] happen at the house won't you
like come over here and check this out
and see if you can figure out what this
is so Marie comes and looks at the dust
and she was like I don't know what that
is she goes in the kitchen to get like a
washcloth or something like that to
start cleaning the dust up and then when
she's in there there's like a puddle of
water on the floor and she slips on it
it sounds like classical folk you guys
go ahead
yeah now is that so she cleans that
puddle up and apparently as soon as she
did that another one yeah that's
poltergeist yeah we'll see that's what I
tell you yes folks guys there's there's
a big thing we didn't have any puddles
in in mind but this whole thing where it
does one thing and then it does it again
and then it does
again and then it does it again it's not
it you know I mean there's no way you
know I mean there's no it's just too
much of a coincidence yeah but in other
cases there was a in a puddles yeah it's
common in other ones but mine didn't
have it that it is if that is a very
common thing and it appears out of
nowhere you don't yes might turn around
there there are places where there
shouldn't be price you just turn around
there it is she clean it up you turn
around there's another one yeah you
didn't see how it got there right well
mine did that but a dish did with like
objects towels or something like a
little hand towels there was one piece
in Atlanta where the puddles were bored
yeah although I would have liked to
three drops of blood appeared in Mars
yeah I got photographs of that Louis
still has the damn piece of paper I got
to get that cuz I'd like to do a DNA
test in that yeah I wonder if there's
one whose blood that is but I would too
bad they didn't grab a sample that blood
to make sure it really was blood and
then figure out whose it was
I think it's blood being teleported out
of the body well the weird I think in
that case as far as I could determine
they did test the blood it was human
blood it wasn't the same type as either
of the people that lived in the house it
was a it was actually an elderly couple
that lived in the house and they did
test the blood it was human oh I
remember that case this is one of the
blood was all throughout the house yeah
oh that was weird I remember that case
and they had lived in the house for a
really long time and nothing had
happened
yeah and just like all of us it like
suddenly apparently one day and it's
just like I hope they were like in their
70s or something yeah and then like
blood started like could have been
somebody bleeding ran through the house
I mean that's well the first thing when
the cops came is that well they thought
like an animal had got in and stuff but
then would they couldn't find an animal
first thing and then when they tested
the blood it was human blood but it
wasn't the same type as according to the
test one of my modern tests would show
it is healing yeah because this was well
it wasn't that long ago it was in the
90s or 2000 so it wasn't like it was a
you know like a long time ago or
anything well that first poltergeist
case had blood and that I was involved
and had blood it was only three drops
yeah and they're pretty small like I've
seen the photo but yeah it wouldn't it
wouldn't support you
it would surprise me if all of that
blood from that case was human yeah I
just don't think that your suck your
unconscious or your subconscious would
steal that much blood from you or
someone else that's what I mean it's
like if I feel like I mean the way they
described it there was like a lot of
blood
yeah and for a while like the cops kind
of had kind of had to close the house
off I'm sorry because um they were like
well this might be a murder scene so
there was like enough blood there to
like be concerning based on what I saw
in the past I don't know if it applies
now if it comes back but based on what I
based on what I saw in the past it was
like a safety mechanism to the
phenomenon she got too scared of his
stop it it had the power to kill a
person but it never did it yeah you know
I mean that's quite rare actually all
that would kill it but I mean all you'd
have to do is put something very heavy
above a door so when you open it it
falls like yeah it's like drunken
[ __ ] it could have done that kind of
[ __ ] at any time it didn't as if there
would have been repercussions or as if
that might not be you know that might be
against the rules somehow or I don't
know I don't know why yeah because you
think I mean it and in particularly in
your case where you said that it could
throw a knife across the room it could
have like stabbed somebody could throw a
nightie throughout the room and the
knife [ __ ] went point forward like a
[ __ ] arrow yeah shot in a straight
line like that one in somebody's head
that would kill him
it wasn't in an arc like thrown in a
straight line like whatever had it still
had it and then as soon as it got to the
damn glass sliding glass doors that
stopped dead and [ __ ] fell right at
my feet pow and it was like a bullet
that's [ __ ] weird this is so fit when
it hit it didn't bounce just like that
remote yeah oh yeah that rare just like
we we said that it looked like there was
a magnet like yeah flora that it just
went and my [ __ ] hair just went like
this I remember you know I mean those
and [ __ ] red was sitting in another
couch over there looking at me and then
his eyes were like that big and I just
shut down I guess that's why I didn't
really want to remember it well yeah
that could be a little traumatic cuz
when I hit the ground it was like three
feet in front of my feet added my feet
down yeah it's like right there
weird hit creepy yeah I think I a
poltergeist thrown and it's two had
cheese on it where Lois was had been
slicing that damn cheddar yeah because
she been cutting cheese yeah and it was
a kitchen knife yeah like the kind you
see me use all time
yeah like are 15 inches long yeah [ __ ]
so yeah so so this case yeah so the so
the lady goes in the [ __ ] kitchen
cleans the puddle up and then another
one sprouts up at this stage they're
like okay well let's cut off the water
supply and see what happens they turn
off the water and puddles still kept
forming like particularly the kitchen
like I was linoleum floor busy I believe
so then the neighbor says okay well
we're gonna call a plumber so they call
the plumber the plumber comes over and
surprise surprise does not find a single
problem yeah just like that usually
disappeared on the linoleum floor anyway
right yeah
yeah so they were just like popping up
and he's like well you don't any leaks
and your pipes are bursting like nothing
is wrong the sink is fine and
everything's fine teleported that water
um so I don't know what to tell you so
the plumber left evidently and the
puddles continued to form for about an
hour after he had left so by that by the
time that evening like came around I
guess Philip and the grandmother like
kind of sit around gonna wonder what
this could be and [ __ ] I think the
neighbor went home at this point but the
the kid and the grandmother they go in
the kitchen
and they see that the counter which had
been cleaned previously had um tea
leaves and sugar like spreaded all over
yeah and then they saw they said they
had like a tea dispenser like his big
thing that they have in the UK I guess
and the button was going in and out on
its own and like squirting tea all over
the counter okay like so they said that
they saw it doing that then they said
while they were in there looking at that
they heard a big crash from the hallway
behind them so then they went out into
the hallway and then they said that
there was a plant there was like a big
plant in a pot and it had been sitting
at the at the base of the staircase
that's where it usually was they said
now the plant was on a step halfway up
like in the dirt and the pot was on the
top
yeah that's their case that's the kind
of [ __ ] that we said that's what they
said yeah so this is very poltergeist do
something like I said you know it's
called the black monk because of like
the apparition that happened but all
this stuff that happened earlier on so
they thought like all poltergeist II
should you would have [ __ ] loved it I
know I'd have been into it had you saw
it when you were a kid though you've
been well yeah it's probably [ __ ]
Louis and Louis and red were just
[ __ ] petrified they just couldn't
figure it out
because I tell you that that [ __ ]
doesn't happen yeah tell you though
that's not true didn't happen it happens
I thought it's a ghost they thought it
was a ghost too but looking back on it I
don't think it's a ghost
but just another it's just some of them
something about physics we have yeah so
about consciousness it's just wait but
this I mean just this this early part of
this case this does seem like because
it's nothing that's particularly
malevolent it's just random [ __ ] yeah
well it's almost kind of like it tries
to entertain you it's definitely trying
to get your attention
yeah you know that's the way it was I
mean we think of just like taking the
plant out of the block
putting the plant and the dirt in on the
step in the middle and then putting the
pot up yeah that's a that's exactly like
something that's I mean it's just rain
that's exactly like something that the
in Mammoth Mountain would happen yeah
that's what I mean I kind of like it's
just random as [ __ ] that it doesn't mean
anything no didn't know it's just so
it's just so you will marvel over it
yeah so we tried to figure it out yeah
yeah and look it wants you to try to
figure it out but it never it defies it
defies you it does not want you to
investigate well because like I said it
does that it seems like it doesn't mean
it doesn't have like any deeper meaning
what it's doing it's just doing random
like detention but I'm telling you man
see it's the unconscious mind yeah so
they're in there looking at this [ __ ]
crazy ass the [ __ ] that the plant did
apparently and then they hear another
sound coming from the kitchen which is
now behind them so they go back into the
kitchen they said that they saw one of
the kitchen cabinets which presumably
was closed that it was like kind of
vibrating yeah and they said they could
hear the dishes inside like rattling it
together
yep you know what I mean that's I kind
of remember I told you about the you
know like for instance the e-liquid
[ __ ] shot glass yeah that's that's
one of the things that you flowing
through it you know yes it's just
something that it does yeah yes because
it's easy to do yeah that's why because
it seems like that's a lot of like
poltergeist cases that people were there
rattling the rattling and the banging
sometimes that's as much as happens on
that yeah like just knocking and stuff
so yeah so they so they hear the dishes
rattling around and then they heard like
a bunch of banging like coming from
other areas of the house then they felt
like that cold wind again so at this
stage they go back across the street and
you know get Marie back because she had
gone back to her house in the mean time
now Marie comes back and by the time she
got back I guess all the banging sounds
had stopped but she did see like the
vibrating cabinet and the rattling
dishes and everything um summary hung
out for a few hours but nothing happened
again while she was there like she had
seen like some of the earlier stuff but
she didn't see some of the things now
before so then like the the kid Phillip
and the grandmother decide they're gonna
go to bed cuz it's getting to be about
bedtime so Marie the neighbor she goes
up to like wish them good night she's
gonna go back to her own house
so she peeks into Philips room saying
hey goodnight kid or whatever and then
there was like a dresser or like a chest
of drawers in Philips room and it
started like
weighing like back-and-forth you know
what I mean
so that kind of freaked them out and at
that point you know fill up in the
grandmother like you know what we're not
sleeping in here this was just like
[ __ ] crazy
so they went across the street to
Marie's house and slept over there for
the night because they were too wigged
out to sleep in the regular house so a
couple of days later the rest of the
family which was you know the mom and
dad and the daughter they came home from
their vacation now by the time they got
home nothing else had happened in the
house you know what I mean like all that
time it was just pretty much that one
day like all this crazy [ __ ] happened
and then like nothing happened so
Phillip and his grandma like start
telling them about all this crazy [ __ ]
that happened and I'm not really sure
that the that mom and dad really
believed them because it wasn't
happening anymore right so they were
just kind of like well we don't know
what to tell you and they're like no for
real it's like all this really crazy
[ __ ] happen while you were gone
there's and they were like well there's
got to be some logical explanation just
like just like everybody in every
haunting episode yes usually the man
says to the wife yeah let's let my uncle
they has to be some logical explanation
red was trying to pull the carpet up and
[ __ ] looking at looking at he thought
there was a secret door in the dead like
a trapdoor there people were clubbed
well that's the first thing to try to
rationalize it but you know I mean I
mean you do have to like you know get to
the bottom of every single like you know
rational explanation of what it could be
before you can pause this kind of [ __ ]
sounds unbelievable to a person who had
never seen it but it does happen I've
seen it
Jennie's seen it she only got a little
taste of it yeah
[ __ ] you know I mean much cooler had
you seen like the full-blown with [ __ ]
well yeah I'm kind of doing it [ __ ]
changes
okay the more we talk about it like I
said we said this on the sidetrack show
the other day the more we talk about it
the more it's probably gonna start I
don't know I was young back then yeah
but I mean we talked about in a bunch
before and then it kind of went started
as like a tantrum monster rap to ramp
that up that's true and it only did a
few little thinner de it's just did like
a couple right I mean so when I was a
kid you could [ __ ] wrap it up pretty
quick well yeah cuz you said it only
went on for what a testosterone
to do with this I need to get on that
[ __ ] TRT Hey
like all kind of like okay some rad for
red 140 and [ __ ] testosterone little
artificial testosterone [ __ ] all
kinds of [ __ ] she'll be flying around
all over my things I think it's partly
linked to the sex drive
[Laughter]
well it's it could be that I have felt
like heard other people say that that it
has this name ID and stuff wait you know
it would make sense I guess yeah at that
time I had that you know so it's like a
booty manifestation man system
manifested the madness in the booty
really I don't know yeah so it's like so
the rest of this family had come back
and they hadn't seen any of it cuz like
I said they'd been away so they were
just kind of like well it was probably
just this than the other thing yada yada
and then nothing happened for two years
yeah two whole years that's I that is
very weird usually my folks guys goes it
goes yeah I came back after a [ __ ] it
what how about 30-something years but
you know trail although other things
happened in the interim but they just
weren't that strong yeah other phenomena
happen yeah this is just weird because
it was like a big two-year gap and then
it seemed like because it seemed like
the initial manifestation from what I
could read about and determine most of
it seemed like it just happened over
like a day or two like while just the
son and the grandmother were in the
house well the neighbor most poltergeist
episodes only last about a week well
yeah
really really short yours was only what
two weeks something like that bout like
that yeah about two weeks yeah I think
it ended up being like two weeks and it
was at several different locations
because it kind of like followed you
around yeah three different locations
yeah yeah that was uh well sort of kinda
two major locations you major locations
in a bunch of little ones yeah we can
count here too sure so that's four
locations so to me it's gotta be you
stuff to have when I was in the Army
though - that's true that's which which
you know I mean there was so it if you
could you know I mean if you could do it
then you
kind of do it anywhere at anytime yeah
but I think it's mostly what round
puberty's our strongest yeah that does
not add to me I mean it you know most of
the cases that I wrote about said there
was over 100 cases that I read about in
that book probably a you know I don't
know the exact figure but at least 90%
if not more of the cases there was a
teenage kid 12 13 4 involved 15 around
that time almost always yeah not always
a girl it seems like it's kind of it I
feel like people get the impression that
it's like always a teenage girl but it
wasn't always probably a little bit more
often a girl than a boy but not really
I mean I've heard you know sometimes
some people will say well no there's a
slight edge towards the girls and then
other authors have said no there's
actually a slight edge towards the boys
yeah I think it's probably 50/50 yeah I
didn't really notice like a huge
disparity to be honest with you it did
seem like the ones that were more a lot
of your ones that were like ones that
like fire starter type poltergeist that
was almost always girls yeah which I
thought was kind of injury to do it you
know sex drive and inhibition yeah it
does seem like that large fact they're
trying to inhibit sexual desire and then
some for some reason fires involved with
that one yeah probably some dudes
suppression trying to suppress sexual
drives yeah comes out comes out in terms
of fire which you would think that fire
would be hard to do but no that'd be
easy to do cuz moving a big object what
you would think would be harder okay
well when you're making fire all you're
doing is like making moving very small
objects molecules yeah you're
accelerating molecules to the point
where they get something gets hot that
[ __ ] boom combust you know and that's
and fire starters you know they've been
many of those actually were documented
over the centuries there's lots of those
it's always girls it is it's almost
always girls I I'm trying to think of
like the cases that I wrote about in
there I think every single one of them
was a girl yeah
at least where they knew where the focus
was yeah maybe now maybe there was one
that was a boy but I'm not really sure I
can't remember boys tend to beat
telekinetic throwers yeah things
levitating things being thrown noises
noises rattling a couple of those cases
of the firestarter girls like the
Thoreau firestarter and ones like that
it's like some of them were like really
destructive like what else one of the
girls burned a whole house down in the
barn and like the whole [ __ ] farms
burn the house down slowly yeah little
spots of little black spots would appear
and go out all over the [ __ ] house
and the walls yeah a lot of them started
like that yeah I think that was one of
them started like that and then she
ended up and then she ended up burning
down I think the chicken coop burned
down first and then like one of the
barns and there's a black girl wasn't it
uh no it was not that one another one
was a black boy it was to it yeah yeah
yeah that was that was in Illinois I
think in the may be in the 40s yeah
that one burned down three houses farm
houses and it was in stuff in the stuff
in the drawers would start smoldering
they'd open if that happened it would
open the drawer and they just find
smoldering clothes yeah it's weird that
was the one that I was thinking of I
think that's a limit and they weren't
even sure that that kid was the focus
but that was him that was a boy if I
remember it but I remember he had an
abusive stepfather he didn't like and
that was part of it the family home
burned down I think they went to stay at
a relative's house and that burned down
they went stayed with another relative
that also burned down you know what I
mean so I don't know if the kid was
actually like a fire starter if he was
just a pirate baby yeah heck it was just
like burning down yeah I remember
writing details of that case they
thought he was a pyromaniac but then
that got debunked because the
investigators [ __ ] said he could have
started these fires yeah cuz he actually
got dragged into court for that and then
the judge like dismissed it because he
didn't see any evidence and the other
places black spots you know I mean on
things where something were a place
almost caught fire yeah and that's very
suspicious why would you almost catch
fire yeah why didn't it catch fire if
he's trying to burn the place down
why did he burn it
you know it was a hot spot yeah it's
like we're almost got it almost caught
it didn't ya and almost all of them
started that way with loot they had like
these little holes and holes and holes
in clothes or like a couch cushion would
you have fire yes probably from the
underside yeah so yeah some of them like
I said those those tend to be the most
destructive because like in terms of
property damage eventually they end up
burning the house down yet that has
happened in an alarming number of his
yeah but yeah so that was so there was a
two-year gap and they burned the house
down to alleviate the stress they're
trying to get out of the house they
don't want to be in the house they don't
wanna be in a house with one of those
parents that's what that's I think
that's that's what's good yeah because I
think this is like some real severe like
emotional it's an attempt most
poltergeist is I think are basically an
attempt either break a family apart or
to bind a family together one of the two
there's always a family dynamic always
well yeah I mean and in the case of that
boy he was trying to break the family
apart he'd like that dude yeah and that
was like the only way he could yeah just
express himself and I remember things
were catching fire when he wasn't even
there yeah that's true he wasn't there I
think that's I think that was one of the
factors that got his case dismissed I
think he was only nine or something yeah
he was right he was only nine and um
that was one of the things cuz he did
get hauled in front of it for you know
for arson fires are breaking out he
could but yeah they said that he was
some of the fires he wasn't there yeah
so you know what I mean which is kind of
interesting if he was doing it being
able to do it fly from far away I didn't
see any reason why based on what I saw
with my phenomenon there's no maximum
effective range if you knew about it you
could do it didn't matter if you were
there or not well and I wrote about this
a little bit in when I was talking about
the Rochdale case where they still had I
mean when Steve Mehra and the team when
they stayed in the house and Rochdale
and none of the family were there they
sent them all away and then and just the
team stayed there yeah didn't matter
[ __ ] still happened they said it wasn't
as extreme as when the family was there
because the daughter was the focus they
you that pretty much think about it if
you're influencing an object okay hey
and you can't touch it what difference
does it make how far away or if it's two
feet away or 200 miles away
there's no it's because it's you know
about the object yeah so you can
influence it yes that's what it is
yes so um all right so there was a
two-year gap in this case and then the
phenomena came back as they say with a
vengeance it got like really really bad
because the first time it had just been
like a few weird little things some
puddles and bangs plant moved [ __ ] like
that this time not so much fun so
there's all these banging and thumping
noises coming from all over the house
much much louder much more frequent than
before the good old blankets being torn
off of people in their sleep
I always scared me but that never
happened that always had the feeling
that that might happen to me when I went
when poltergeist was going on but it
never did my um my all my aunt's that
grew up in my grandfather's house which
I think I've talked about before on one
of the shows which they said was haunted
cuz they all grew up in it I lived in it
for many years and never heard or saw
anything but several of my aunt's said
that when they were kids there their
blankets got torn off all that yeah yeah
I was also afraid that something might
touch my feet I think those little kids
are scared of that that's why you put
the feet underneath the blanket yeah
although nowadays I can just leave I was
afraid that the [ __ ] poultrygeist
would touch my feet I was like man
something grabbed my foot oh yeah well
said well nowadays I'm just I'm so used
to Pookie climbing all over me when it
doesn't even wake me up before she's up
there like she went on my toes and [ __ ]
I'm like just but yeah so blankets being
torn off of people there'd be [ __ ] like
paintbrushes candlesticks getting kind
of flying around the house one weird
thing that several witnesses said that
the poltergeist would do was that it
would take eggs that were apparently
because the eggs were in the frigerator
as you would put them you know you put
in the frigerator they would take the
eggs from out of the frigerator and then
break them in midair like in front of
people I'd like to see that yeah like a
couple of them report so they actually
saw the egg break blinking in mid-area
apparel and what that would look like
apparently so we just teleported right
in front of them and [ __ ] him that's
where I can that's what it sounded like
that sound like they said I didn't see
anything like that but what can a yeah
that would be pretty weird since was
like said that's pretty crazy um another
thing it would do was it would it would
it would take like all the food out of
the fridge and like spread it on the
floor like well no one was like I knew
you know I mean like it was just like
pop I've heard of a case one time where
eggs were just falling on the floor in
front of the refrigerator as if it had
fallen through the door yeah I've heard
of that didn't see it coming through the
door yeah they just saw motion and the
egg breaking in front of the dam there
was a case in Australia
Humpty do because Australia has the best
place that's some weird of all these
cheer wait fun we love you guys you're
feeling better names is you guys I love
it
but yeah so there was a case like that
in there we're ready though they are you
[ __ ] approve but they had a they had
a thing where I mean a whole bunch of
bad [ __ ] happened in that particular
case but they had a thing where like
eggs were flying around and breaking all
the time to like they've come out of the
fridge but apparently some of those some
of these witnesses in the blackmont case
said that they saw eggs essentially like
a port yeah that if they're frigerator
and just like break somewhat an apple or
yes I mean in my case there's a lot of a
poor tations things just appearing yeah
they were just it well it's things like
simultaneously like disappearing from
place and appear right at another place
things would appear in a room usually
behind your back or right out of your
[ __ ] line of sight and the objects
would be from another room and it wasn't
there a second ago
the only way could have got in there is
from you know maybe like the doorway but
the door didn't open to let it in
it was weird man [ __ ] yeah they were
it's like a teleportation thing
well yeah you said the you know a lot of
the [ __ ] that it but you could never
really catch it yeah you can catch it
happening with your eyes I tried it was
always just right out of it almost kind
of like you seeing it my influence that
are prevented which I think that goes
back to the damn quantum physics with
like you know I mean the Heisenberg
uncertainty principle we're looking at
something confirms its place in space
and time
so therefore the things that you're not
observing their place and location are
not confirmed yeah therefore it can it
can manipulate those so we can be doing
all kind of crazy right yeah because
you're not looking at it but I did see
some things [ __ ] come fly at me like
a pen you know yeah so it didn't it
didn't it wasn't consistent
it does seem though that I mean 99.99%
of cases of people that have reported
this type of stuff I've never heard
anybody say that they saw a thing
begin to move no it's already yeah
that's what it seemed like even when I
saw the remote control I didn't see it
come up off the table I saw it when it
was already moved a couple inches above
the table already I didn't see it lift
off the table is moving did it look like
a streak or did when it moved into a
barber at all I can't really remember
honestly I just remember the sound of a
hit Nate yeah it just made a really
weird noise in it like it like it was
really heavy yeah and it did not which
it was very weird yeah and we tried
dropping it because we wanted to see
what it sounded like and it was like
kicking yeah it didn't sound anything
like that but when it when it fell like
in the supernatural way I'm getting that
it was it was more like boom it was like
that yeah like it like it was a cement
block or yeah it was very didn't bounce
either now the wind shut when you when
you made that same throw just with your
hand you hit the ground
yes house and it had a different sound
and everything you have a stuff
covariance we're now another thing that
it did other than the egg thing was we
cut away I come back s on it the
continuity error times annuity era not
really it's just because we stopped yeah
but yeah what do you brew fill this
drink I'm gonna do mine on the actual
break but yeah so apparently another
thing that it would do was one of the I
guess one of the preachers relatives
like came over and was like oh man this
is such [ __ ] or whatever and then
all of a sudden like it afforded some
milk out of the fridge and dumped it on
his head so right here
wow that's pretty powerful that's pretty
powerful yeah I mean if it's true it was
true also supposedly tore one of joe and
jeans wedding photos in half yeah this
was another one where like I said even
though the the initial manifestations
were just like one or two days and then
stopped for two years but then when it
started back again it went on for quite
a while and it was kind of a thing where
[ __ ] was going on pretty much all the
time kind of like yours was just like
very commonplace they also kind of
seemed to think it was a ghost
they called it Fred yeah because they
said most of the time it did prank like
[ __ ] like that where he would like break
two eggs it would like you know through
all the show to the fridge or whatever
however it also did some more troubling
things they did have an exorcist in to
bless the house as you would and while
he was doing his thing apparently the
walls started like five [ __ ]
vibrating and like banging and [ __ ] like
that like [ __ ] upside down across the
start appearing on the walls and all
this other kind of crap appearing on the
walls what I what is it
any details not really talking about
something rope or drew across I guess
where it turned across them side down
yeah I don't know if they had any
crosses on their walls it's basically
all the sources I saw said that it drew
them on there so I'm assuming that it
drew them on there with chalk or
something that it had
that had like that um also this is
probably the most famous aspect of the
case and if you've seen there was a 2012
British movie that's called when the
lights went out and it is loosely based
on this poltergeist case I actually
tried to watch it I wanted to like rent
it like for Sriman or something and it's
not on streaming which in this day and
age seems right bizarre movie nobody
owns it but I couldn't
yeah so cuz I wanted to watch it I've
seen clips of it because like I saw some
other shows that had clips of it and
[ __ ] but he's had some actors I
recognize but I was like I wouldn't have
minded seeing that movie honestly but I
couldn't see it I guess
let's do this right I need to get like a
VPN so I can like watch British Netflix
and British shutter or whatever I don't
know if British has it but I know that
British British Netflix has some movies
that we don't have in a vice-versa right
so if you get like a VPN you can watch
Netflix in any country you want which is
kind of bread
um but yeah so I so I couldn't watch it
so I don't know how good it is or I've
heard it's not super accurate I mean
obviously it's just kind of like when
when they did the conjuring 2 and it was
based on the Enfield case run they went
wildly off the rails with like what
really happened in that case and they
just like completely like fictionalized
[ __ ] which I understand you have to make
a better movie and stuff but even the
three-part BBC series they did on the
Enfield one like the fictionalization
the first two episodes were good and
stuck pretty much to the story and then
the third one just went like [ __ ]
batshit insane they tried to [ __ ]
like put an ending on it well they had
to conjure a gasket I guess right James
Wan that [ __ ] when really the real
Enfield poltergeist case didn't really
have an ending and a lot of them build
you know just they usually just kind of
like fizzing away you know so it's not
like a big yeah there definite doesn't
connect circe ism or anything like that
yeah it doesn't come to like a climax
yeah just using those guys with a
whimper yeah either that or there's like
one big last thing and then it's like
kind of like there's one thing
it just does happen anymore yeah like
there's no explanation that's what and
that that type of thing doesn't make a
good movie it's like even though that's
how real life works all right at the
time I can see why they don't do that in
movies because it's not like it there's
no narrative you know what I mean it's
just a bunch of random [ __ ] happens and
then it stops and it didn't mean
anything
the mammoth mountain one that I was
involved in you know it didn't really
stop until I started to suspect it I had
something to do with it yeah I started
to make try to make it move things and
they stopped yeah it didn't do you see I
didn't see it but you said I mean the
last thing that happened before you
realize that was a pretty minor thing it
just moved like a perfume bottle or yeah
and then I said and then I started to
command it to move the perfume in a way
because it moved like from the bathroom
into the wall behind you yeah but that
was like super minor compared to the
other [ __ ] that had happened that's what
I mean it so it so it wasn't like it
ended with some big like no revelatory
and when I tried to hijack my nurses I
tried to hijack it like a superpower
yeah move this [ __ ] that was it yeah
vanished it's all but well like you said
it's almost kind of like you
acknowledging yes you doing it yeah kind
of like takes all the power away there's
something about some kind of inner
conflict between your conscious mind and
the subconscious mind you know I mean if
you start saying well it must be my
unconscious doing it then that all of a
sudden it kind of short-circuits it and
whatever conflict you had going on
between your consciousness and your
unconsciousness is resolved as soon as
you recognize you're the one that behind
it and then just fizzles well and I feel
tried to make it make it do things and
once you do that you've accepted that
you have something to do with it yeah in
a way well and I think too in a lot of
cases where we're maybe if these
manifestations happened because of you
know an emotionally troubled teenager
yeah they don't have plausible
deniability anymore because what they're
doing is they're punishing themselves or
they're punishing the family because
they don't know any other way to do that
and it's happening unconsciously that
they're doing on purpose but as soon as
they realize that that's what's
happening it only worked when I thought
it was an outside force yeah that's what
I mean
so you don't really you don't have that
like thing to blame it on anymore at
least you know for you have to kind of
own it at least at that period in my
life I had to be an outside force yeah
and as I started to think well [ __ ] I'm
gonna do this [ __ ] I couldn't believe it
at first that I had anything to do with
it
well you said at first that you thought
that it was still an outdoors worried my
mom reading your mind yeah it was doing
what you know what I was thinking about
yeah yeah I thought it was I thought it
was for reading my mind yeah and then I
said no it's not reading my mind I must
be doing this in those days you know at
my age I didn't know anything about an
unconscious yeah yeah I mean I only
thought that you are just your
consciousness that's it but some part of
me went okay that I might [ __ ] make
it dude I'm gonna make it do this I got
real like [ __ ] co-active about it man
up on the ship yeah it advantaged yeah
you're a long long time yeah for a long
time but yeah so probably the most
famous not famous aspect of this case
was that this poltergeist in particular
seemed to target as is usually the case
the thirteen-year-old girl
Diana Diane she was 12 when they moved
in she was 13 it was her the whole time
that's probably I mean even though the
[ __ ] started when she wasn't there
it does seem like I mean that might have
been I don't know that might have been
something like weird anomalous type of
thing or she knew about place though
right she did yeah they thought they had
been living there for a little while so
yeah so this little girl was apparently
pretty much thrown out of bed on several
occasions one very famous instance which
was in the movie was the entity
apparently dragged her up the stairs by
the neck and left like a bunch of
bruises like on her throat that happen
in real life to supposedly supposedly
I'm what it felt like that's what the
family said also in the movie they
showed like their cuz you know there's a
very famously that and it's still there
cuz they have the house kind of they
left the house the way it was when the
poltergeist should happen there so
there's like Osmonds posters and all
kind of [ __ ] like in the kids rooms or
whatnot
so there's this big like grandfather
clock like on the landing and apparently
that kind of came flying down the stairs
at some point too and they did put that
in the movie and I heard that they did
report that so this did like some
allegedly reportedly it did some kind of
violent [ __ ] I wonder what it feels like
to touch you I've never had it touch me
know it touched Lois she said that it
she'd just felt like a cold hand that
went around her waist and snaked down
one of her legs and then [ __ ]
disappear down to the end of the floor I
saw it happening to her but I see
anything she said it she said she could
kind of feel an arm on it but it snaked
around her like ass big snake
interesting they said it felt cold yeah
it went fast like three seconds went
around her waist and then [ __ ] coiled
down one leg and it felt like you know
because it had she said it felt like it
was about two or three feet long and it
kind of snaked around and then it went
down through the floor huh I saw a guy
standing next to her and I was standing
in the doorway that was after the damn
cover came off there yeah pillows flew
up that was one of those things they
actually saw like happen right yeah one
of the few things that they saw move I
didn't see it they saw it yeah alright
when I heard them scream when the [ __ ]
thing when the when the pillows flew
then I ran there and saw Lois dancing
[Laughter]
yes so this actually this type of [ __ ]
you know getting thrown around like all
the [ __ ] flying around it banging and
all this if this went on like a couple
of years which again is unusual so but
it took that long for this particular
manifestation for which the whole case
is named the black monk to actually
start appearing before this it had just
been like your standard poltergeist
stuff albeit reportedly much more severe
than most of these cases were
most people in these cases don't don't
say they get thrown around or burn down
stairs or anything like that I think
South Shields didn't she have didn't she
get thrown down the stairs and have her
leg broken in that case I don't know the
South Shields poltergeist it was that
South Shields or was that another one of
us it was another British case than I'm
thinking about but there was at least
one case where the girl said she got
thrown down the stairs by the
poltergeist and it broke her leg very
rare that anyone's actually hurt yeah
there was one and actually there was one
case in Brazil where the little girl
died
and they thought they weren't sure that
if it was because the because she died
from like there was poison in her coke
and they're not sure if like it boys uh
ported in there yeah or if she did it to
herself you know because it had been
beating her up for a really long time
she got really beat up by this book the
other report was like the Bell which
which sounded a lot like a poltergeist
pretty model I put it in my book as a
poltergeist yeah even though I'm not
sure I don't think that case happened I
don't think a lot of problems with that
that we the whole show about that yeah
that sounded a lot like a work of
fiction it did indeed yeah cuz because
you can disprove several key events like
the president come to see it yeah that
didn't happen it didn't happen I don't
know why that got added on into the
legend later on it's a great story I'm
not saying that yeah and I'm soaked lore
and it sounds like the story is based
based on real poltergeist events that it
maybe happened somewhere else some of
the phenomena sounds like something that
happens in poltergeist but I don't think
Bell which actually happened that's some
[ __ ] you gotta watch especially like
some of the old cases and I did put him
in the book and everything but I do feel
like the kind of you know the kind of
story of poltergeist like what they do
that was kind of like pretty established
quite early on yeah and it kind of got
around it was like a meme you know what
I mean that they do this particular
thing that particular thing and it's
interesting to to see that during some
time periods some tight
of manifestations were more common than
rock throw weight yeah like you know
rocks falling on the roof or some [ __ ]
like that or another weird thing too and
I noticed this was a bunch of cases is
that in a lot of times you would get
like the rock throwing and it would also
go with like a talking poltergeist which
the Bell which was as well that would
kind of like that new [ __ ] that happened
like in the town like it would gossip
about it or would like you know insult
people yeah that was like a thing yeah
the Bell which wasn't the only case
where that's why I'm kind of like
skeptical a lot of the Bell Witch stuff
because I've read like a lot of other
cases quote-unquote that had those very
same and I and I just wondered if that
was like a storytelling device at the
time or something that was like popular
in folklore at the time stories that
sound like poltergeist pretty accurately
have been you know and I'm saying
poltergeist based on what I saw as a kid
seemed to come for about the fifteen
hundreds that's when they first started
mentioning poultra things that sound
like poltergeist
1500 yeah there are older ones but
they're a little different yeah which
you know people change maybe the
manifestation might have changed over
time yeah I mean kind of like it does
what you expect it to do because it's in
a way kind of like psychokinesis well
yeah we've talked about that that maybe
it's like there's an element of
self-fulfilling prophecy in it it's like
because it does seem like because that
whole chapter in the book about ones
that seemed like demons or that people
thought were demons and in my opinion if
that [ __ ] really happened the way they
said it did it was probably just because
the people were expecting it were a
particular religion or expecting it to
act like a demon so it acted like a
demon because it was that was what the
focus would be receiving it as the
underlying [ __ ] thread is always like
religiosity and superstition yeah you
have to have that and young people yeah
that seems to be it seems to be like
what you need yeah the perfect storm
right and
around around puberty yeah but at this
stage so like I said this little girl is
apparently getting beat up and thrown on
the bed thrown down the stairs and
whatnot but it wasn't until a few years
after the [ __ ] had started that they
started seeing and the mom and dad I
believe started seeing this first they
started calling it the black monk
because it was just this shadow figure
that looked like it had a hood on and
several people reported seeing it um Joe
and gene Pritchard said that they would
see it standing by their bed at night
you know what I mean like kind of
standing over their bed but they
couldn't see its face it basically just
looked like a shadow with a hood like of
a hooded figure which is they perceived
it as a monk and that's why they started
like calling it that because that's what
it looked like well mine was just a blue
haze so maybe in another case maybe you
could get to manifest and I found when I
was like researching these cases like I
I found a photograph I'm not sure what
year it was taken that somebody took in
the house and it there was like a like a
black figure it didn't look like a monk
though it but honestly when I looked at
it and then I kind of brightened it up I
thought I saw like tennis shoes tennis
shoes yeah so I can be wrong might be
faked yeah but or it might just be like
a weird like double exposure or somebody
was like in there and they ran out real
quick or some [ __ ] like that because
when I was looking at I was like oh
that's kind of creepy looking and then
like I lightened it I'm like are this
have shoes yeah I can't tell those are
tennis shoes it looked like maybe
somebody was tentative and I may tell
you man you know whenever I saw the
poltergeist there wasn't any kind of
physical manifestation with it yeah I
mean it doesn't need to manifest itself
into any kind of image yeah just objects
moving well like I said I don't know I
mean you haze I mean if if what we're
saying about it is correct that it comes
from the unconscious mind and in a lot
of ways that comes it it acts the way
your unconscious mind expects it to act
yeah if you think it's a ghost you might
you might actually start yeah you might
actually be able to conjure
up the if you know your like image of a
ghost I would guess or you think you're
seeing it maybe that's what it is so
apparently a lot of people have seen
this quote-unquote black monk the
pritchards that they saw at first some
of their neighbors saw it some other
people so some other people have seen it
like through the window like from
outside
and it got seen by pretty much all the
family members of the neighbors and [ __ ]
like that around the house over the
years now evidently it went away after
that um so after the phenomena stopped
ten years later they actually got a
paranormal investigator in there and he
was like looking under the house he also
went into the history of the house and
according to him I don't know if this is
true or not but he said that where the
house stood or at least the area around
there used to be a priori
which had been there from 1092 1539 and
that where the pritchards house was 30
East Drive was where there were there
was gallows so I don't know if that's
true or not because that seems like
something a lot of paranormal
investigators say yes sounds kind of
convenient so yes so he's kind of saying
oh maybe somebody you maybe some monk
was there and he you know did something
bad and they hang them or I don't know
but it just seems like whatever that it
seems like like you said like too
convenient now as I said before
apparently okay so they said that the
[ __ ] stopped however the lady that lives
next door Carol who like I said is very
ready to like just let ghost hunting
teams in there she still lives there as
far as I know because the I I was
watching I can't read the name of it the
guy I'd the one guy that does the show
his channel is called curiosity he was
another one that I watched he did one on
the Manchester pusher like a two-part
series he did a two-part [ __ ] on this
too and he stayed in the house like a
couple of nights yeah and he's funny
because he's just like totally skeptical
so he just like went in there and stayed
and he just like sat there in the dark
and then like called out the black monk
like calling him a [ __ ] and stuff yeah
and nothing happened now I saw this
other show like these two Ghost Hunters
who went there and they
dr. Carroll as well and she was like
telling them all these stories about all
this crazy [ __ ] that happened to her and
her daughter and all her other relatives
every time they come in there so go my
daughter won't even come in here and you
know she'd get thrown at her and it's
like she won't you know some of them
said that they'd seen the black monk as
well and these two went in there and
they kind I guess they have more of like
a straight-ahead paranormal show I mean
the curiosity is more like he does true
crime he does paranormal he does all
kind of different things but these two
this was like a paranormal show so they
were kind of like hey do you hear that
hey do you hear that you know what I
mean so it was kind of like that and I
didn't really see anything and really
hear anything and it was like a really
long show so I couldn't sit through the
whole thing because it was boring but um
it's like nothing mothered nothing much
is going on but as I said I will note
that when Carroll was in the house and
as I said she will go on and on because
they were just like the first [ __ ] in
half an hour or 45 minutes of the show
was just her talking like about [ __ ]
that happened in the house like when
they and they were just kind of like oh
interesting okay like can you please
leave so I can do our investigation like
they didn't say that but I kind of feel
like maybe that's because she does she
does go on she seems like a charming
woman but while she was there they were
walking around the house and she was
like tell him yeah this should happen
here and there whatever and then like
apparently marbles and pennies were like
appearing in places where they had just
you know been and there was nothing
there you know what I mean
because like so like they came down the
steps and then they went over to like
this it's not a coal cellar but it's
like a like a coal closet it's like a
closet where they used to keep all the
coal when they used to have that back in
the day and apparently it's like some
really bad [ __ ] happen in there so they
were coming back down to look at that
and then they turned around and then
there was like a marble at the bottom of
the staircase and they're like well that
wasn't there before because we would
have stepped on it but then I was just
kind of like well that that just seems
really I don't know it just seems like
an easy thing to fake I'm not saying
anybody faked it I wasn't conclusive
it's yeah that's what I'm saying it's
inconclusive it's like one that marble
could have been there before and you
just didn't notice it
- somebody could have just dropped it
out their pocket I'm not naming any
names I'm just saying that that could
have happened
so I don't know I didn't see anything in
any of the investigations that have
happened recently in the last classic
poltergeist requires a focus is usually
a young person and nobody lives in there
any nobody lives in there now than most
likely the poltergeist phenomena is not
not going on now Carroll has said and I
don't know how reliable she is Carroll
has said because she lives like I said
she lives in this is semi-detached so
it's like a duplex kind of are all
although I think sometimes there's three
of them I can't remember but um she has
said that she's seen it the thing like
going through the walls and that [ __ ]
has happened at her house as well
because it's technically the same house
you know what I mean but they're
separated by wall so I don't know I
don't know if I believe her that just
sounds it sounds like two different
phenomena there's the conflict there
because the first part of the part of
the story sounds like classic poker
that's what I'm saying the second part
sounds like haunting and there's a
difference yeah and I do feel like them
I do feel like everyone on earth well I
conflate them and that's like not I
don't know if that's necessarily if you
really delve into the [ __ ] [ __ ]
you're gonna see that those are two
separate phenomena and people are always
trying to put them together but you know
I saw a poltergeist Jenny saw it there
was no ghost was her no I didn't see a
ghost either and I didn't get that
feeling but it was like but well I don't
like I said if there's poltergeist
phenomena I don't think it's like
spirits or anything like that because I
don't believe in that
I I'm not saying that they're learned
that I was valid I don't believe in
during the Mammoth Mountain thing I saw
a poltergeist phenomenon what is called
fault poltergeist phenomena I thought it
was a ghost but I didn't see a ghost and
I'm proof of that everything pointed
more towards what they would call back
in the 60s fuck'em classic poltergeist
yeah which is our spk recurrence which
is what this face mostly seems like
except for that several people have said
that they saw an apparition - phenomenon
yeah of apparitions are [ __ ]
apparitions
require a [ __ ] it's not the only time
that that's happened I do have a section
in my book where people said where other
where poltergeist [ __ ] was going on but
people have also reported seeing
apparitions not always human apparitions
they're usually just like shadow figures
that they're like very indistinct it's
not like they see like hey it's grandma
or anything like that yeah it's usually
like this like a like a black shadow
figure a white shadow figure some of the
guys like this way when I was at mammoth
the only thing I would ever call an
apparition was that damn blue haze it
may be like blurs yeah moving blurs or a
round kind of ball that kind of looked
like it was there but here's the weird
thing about these apparitions everyone
would be there with me and we weren't
quite sure we saw yeah we could agree at
the same time do you see that yeah I
guess there's something weird something
there you know I mean but you just
it was fit was very [ __ ] vague you
know I mean you you you could all kind
of agree that yeah I feel like there's
something there but when you try to
focus your eyes directly on it it wasn't
there was always like something that you
had to kind of look off a little bit to
the side to see it a soldier would know
what I'm talking about at night if when
you don't have any night-vision goggles
if you look directly at an object you
can't see it yeah but if you have to
look a little bit you look a little bit
aside you could kind of see it yeah a
little bit that's the way the blue haze
was yeah you had to kind of look a
little bit off to the side and you could
kind of see it out I was not really the
corner of your eye but you know I mean
you had to be looking at maybe had to
get 30 degrees had to give it a little
bit of side eye and we always kind of
felt like something was watching us from
that direction and you know I mean it
and it was like you looked at a hallway
and into the room that whole doorway
looked kind of like a blue haze was in
that room yeah if you looked directly
into the room you couldn't see the blaze
but if you look a little bit off to the
side you could kind of see it so it
didn't look like smoke particles or
anything like that it wasn't anything
that was there physically it was some
kind of energy it's the only way I can
say it you
you said it was hard to describe you
only said it was kind of like it's kind
of like when you go into a room where a
bunch of people have been smoking a long
time ago and it's just like kind of
hanging ya know lights coming in and
it's yeah a luminescent it was kind of
like that he didn't see any wisps or
anything yeah it was just like a solid
yeah it looked like a field kind of like
a field but then if you tried to focus
your eyes on it it would vanish yeah it
was just weird so what is that
is that is that an apparition well I
guess it would be technically it was
right I mean just cuz it doesn't look
like a person does not mean but as I
said it's and it would come and go yeah
it'd be there for a few minutes you'd be
standing there me and red talking about
it and then he go it's gone and I go
yeah it's not there anymore yeah be like
that
as I said it's it does seem like there
are a few cases like poltergeist cases
where it was pretty much all classic
poltergeist [ __ ] like this but then
every now and then people would see like
I said not usually humanoid but if they
were humanoid they were very very
indistinct it just seemed like a shadow
or like a white blur that sort of
suggested a person or a ball or
something like that
I only saw blurs when things moved yeah
you know so I wonder is that I mean I'm
like I said I've never seen a ghost
about a ghost and I'll think I really
believe in them in the sense that I
don't believe in them in the sense that
you know III don't think someone's
consciousness survives in a form that
could come back that looks that is
recognizably that form like I said it's
not like your grandma came back going
hey I buried five hundred dollars in the
yard like you know what do you mean I
don't believe in any of that kind of
stuff um I don't know man when I had
that out-of-body experience my roommates
saw it but he wouldn't tell me exactly
what he saw but I think what he
experienced was the same thing you
experience when you have that feeling of
someone watching yeah yeah that's what I
think so I just wonder about that's like
they do know they do know that there is
a part of your brain because if they put
that [ __ ] you know Michael Persinger
that does those experiments with the god
helmet yeah
if they
do like little electrical stimulation of
certain parts of your brain and they
know where it is they can make you feel
like somebody's watching you yeah so
there is like come some kind of receptor
like in your brain for that particular
thing and they can do it on purpose like
they can stimulate that area or brain
and you will think that there is someone
else in the room with you yeah you know
what I mean so well during a poltergeist
event you're a few that's being
stimulated like [ __ ] crazy yeah and
like I said I've had that happen a few
times not you know pretty much the worst
was in Big Lots that time and then one
time at my grandma's house when I
thought someone was standing behind me
right I've had it happen here a couple
of times like I've been like this was
like probably like a year ago
and I think I was in the kitchen I was
like washing the dishes or some [ __ ] and
again I could swear that so I didn't
think somebody was right behind me I
thought somebody was standing with a
dryer where the washer and dryer like
right at the door of the laundry room
which is like right off the kitchen I
thought they were standing there looking
at me yeah and I had to like turn around
look and it kind of freaked me out
you know all right so we're going to I
guess it's time to take a break cuz buy
my drinks empty and when we come back
we're gonna talk about yet another weird
poltergeist case from the UK this one
from Wales actually this is the brother
dolly case so we'll be back in just a
few minutes what's up
what you doing just gonna lay there yeah
okay
you love true crime I love true crime
and I've spent the last three years
compiling a series of the most
intriguing unsolved murders of the 20th
century it's called the faceless villain
and volume three is available now
featuring such fascinating cases as the
Caddy murders the carry baby's case the
fraud boys the al-qasr murders and the
inokashira park dismemberment incident
the faithless villain volume three is an
involving exploration of unsolved slang
spanning the years from 1980 to 1999
pick up your copy and print or eBook
formats on Amazon or download the
audiobook version from audible.com and
get ready for a chilling journey through
modern crime history
all right we're back second half talking
about poltergeist kids now this one this
is a very weird case and I feel like
there was like a lot of publicity around
it like when it first happened like this
kind of occurred like from 1997 to 2001
and it was kind of like a lot of [ __ ]
going on around that time but then kind
of after that it sort of seemed to fade
away a little bit
this one has aspects of poltergeist [ __ ]
it has aspects of haunting type [ __ ]
apparition type [ __ ] and also a little
bit of like a weird like religious
overtone which you know this is a really
weird I really don't know this game and
I'm just saying from the outset I'm not
sure how much of this case that I
believe because I think there was some
chicanery no perhaps alright going on at
some point alright but this actually
happened in North Wales in beginning in
1997 now the strange thing about this
one so apparently the story goes that
the whole thing started in March of 1997
now at that stage a letter appears in a
local newspaper in this town in North
Wales the letter had been written by
this Irish couple the Dooleys and they
said that they had been on vacation in
North Wales and they had been walking in
a field near this farmhouse which was
done by the Gower family who will come
into play later on now the Dooleys said
that while they were walking around in
this field they stopped and they were
like looking at a mountain or some [ __ ]
like that and then they said that they
had seen an apparition of the Virgin
Mary know right yeah she which right
that's how you go and like I said this
is just like the opening salvo so don't
get like too wrapped up in this but so
they said they saw the Virgin Mary it
made them feel really awesome
whatever illnesses or injuries or
whatever they
and were miraculously healed hallelujah
oh you know all that regular kind of
stuff
I don't mean to sound glib it's just
that this kind of stuff is just kind of
like okay because I this kind of [ __ ]
always reminds me of do you remember I
don't know if you know but there was a
building in Clearwater for a long time
where the the sprinkler had sprayed like
the palm oil from the palm trees like up
on this one particular window and the
window had this like stain on it that's
sort of if you squinted kind of maybe
looked like the Virgin Mary there so
there's a long history and there was a
whole like so people would come and like
put flowers on the [ __ ] like buy the
thing of the building I've seen the
Virgin Mary and a piece of toast well
remember that one do you have to marry
toast well there is a toaster now that
will deliberately put the Virgin Mary or
it's either the Virgin Mary the face of
Jesus I could use I wanted to you guys
I'm like whoever came up with that the
mind is an incredible fact the mind is
very incredible you could pick out a
[ __ ] you can pick out [ __ ] I feel
like isn't there somebody that saw it
was either Jesus or the Virgin Mary and
it was like in a grilled cheese sandwich
or something they kept that [ __ ] like in
a [ __ ] Tupperware they were trying to
say on eBay
and we're trying to sell it on eBay they
probably all moldy and [ __ ] yeah that's
[ __ ] up
yeah it's not the Virgin Mary hey man
gotta make money that's some pareidolia
right there no if I if I saw the Virgin
Mary and something I might want might I
might try to sell it on eBay
oh I would for sure try it because a
believer might want if there's a lot of
dumbasses up there well I just I mean
I'd be a dumbass maybe just somebody who
wants a picture of what wants a [ __ ]
an image of the Virgin Mary and
something and and as you wait you wait
long enough you're gonna get it first
and has three hundred dollars later on
to just piss away yeah well maybe for
you maybe it's an all maybe maybe it's
like a voted movies like I'm offering
I think it's an offering to our to our
lady yeah yeah so I like Catholicism
there I do it's pretty pimpin I'm [ __ ]
fancy you have to admit that their
Cathedral
are they got the best music the best
looking at all
what's up they got the best music they
got the best visuals they got it all
there's stained glass windows a lot of
that [ __ ] yeah honestly my favorite um I
mean when I was in the UK I was super
alive I'm not religious or anything and
like I used to love to get all this
[ __ ] old cathedrals and like go look
at the stainless I love stained glass
windows that's one of my favorite things
like when I would go to the Met in New
York they have a whole wing of like
medieval this is the medieval wing and
they have like all these [ __ ]
stained-glass windows and like all it's
like illuminated manuscripts and like
all those beautiful Bibles and [ __ ] like
that these have [ __ ] gorgeous man and
I would spend like [ __ ] hours in
there looking at that [ __ ] I don't
believe in that stuff
but it's just kind of like it's just
it's gorgeous yeah you know what I mean
it it's just kind of like they do they
do kind of know how to do the [ __ ]
Catholics the guys know that yeah
exactly even you don't have to believe
in it what are you doing poke poke he's
coming to visit she's she's a guest on
the show at least it's not her bar know
what she's doing she's laying down
behind the monitor well if you see the
camera move this booth that's that's her
big issues yeah she's laying erupted I'm
just trying to like I keep doing that
big like she was trying to boss some
[ __ ] I don't want her steppin on the
laptop cuz it'll like [ __ ] up their
recording yes so this is how the whole
[ __ ] started so in 1997 these people and
it wasn't even at the house it was like
in a field near the people's house right
and they said they saw the Virgin Mary
all their [ __ ] was healed they felt
awesome Palelei all that kind of stuff
now notably well according to them the
family that lived in the house the gaurs
this was rosemary was the wife and then
she had a husband named David and then
they had a son named John Paul who who
was adopted he out he and he had Down
syndrome now the couple when they first
heard about this story of like these
people seeing the Virgin Mary in their
field they were like whatever [ __ ]
and they just basically said to the
media we have to just think it's silly
and it's like whatever I don't we don't
know what you're talking about but it
does seem like and like I said this is
kind of all from their point of view so
I don't know how true any of this [ __ ]
is but the gaolers did say
well the fact that somebody said they
saw the Virgin Mary like so close to her
house kind of got us interested in like
paranormal kind of stuff so what they
started doing particularly rosemary she
started taking photographs just like all
around the house and around like the
field around the house and stuff I guess
because she's kind of like maybe I want
to see the Virgin Mary and she was like
stir trend you know taking pictures like
see what what happened now one of the
pictures that she took which was of a
barn on their property and I've seen
this picture
I don't know how legit it is it does
what kind of creep you have to say she
took this picture of the barn and their
property and in one of the windows is
what appears to be a face and it does
look like a face I I will say that so
the this photograph was published in the
newspaper
and of course the newspaper was like hey
it's the Virgin Mary because those
people would like seeing the Virgin Mary
there before and now we've taken a
picture in the window of the barn and
that's the Virgin Mary also um and then
after that rosemary said that she saw an
apparition what she called a blurry
white figure moving through the field I
don't think she said that it was the
Virgin Mary necessarily but she said
that it was walking through the field
and after she said that then just like
the building in clear water with the
palm oil up on the window all these
people started coming to this field and
like leaving flowers and [ __ ] that was
Clearwater Florida
well the window was yeah would have
something famous what if they
Scientologists have to see it no you you
think they would have weighed in on that
[ __ ] it's actually Xena ya know they say
that's actually see that they're like no
that's [ __ ] LRH yes what can l ron
Hubbard I mean it was so vague it
honestly could have been anybody yeah
you know what I mean it would be awesome
it didn't really look like a person it'd
be awesome if [ __ ] Scientologists are
seeing l ron Hubbard in [ __ ] toast
why haven't they gone in on that that
seems like something they would get in
on yeah I mean but [ __ ]
Scientologists you guys Clearwater yeah
I'm just you know what I mean it's like
I only lived there for eight months I
lived in Tampa for a while but I moved
to Clearwater cuz I got a job there and
not everybody in Clearwater is a
Scientologist I'm not saying that but
because that's their headquarters and a
lot of the downtown like even the
buildings like the restaurants and stuff
like that even if they're not like up
front like Scientology they're owned by
Scientologists um so you kind of get
this weird thing or at least I did where
you feel like wherever you go that
they're watching you or they're like all
because you every time when they are
they got cancer I would just go to a
little [ __ ] grocery store and be like
is that one of the pod people are you
hot people it's like I started feeling
like invasion of the Body Snatchers like
you didn't know like which ones had been
taken over
they got closed-circuit TVs everywhere
it started freaking me out I the lian
people on the streets everywhere I had
to move I was only there for eight
months and I was like [ __ ] this I'm
getting out of here I didn't like it I
didn't I like it so and and I'm not like
a paranoid person or anything like that
but it's just I worked with them the
kapu
what's she doing she I look into the
lights playing around the light he's
rolling yes she's that funny so yeah so
all these people start coming to this
[ __ ] field um you know saying they
felt like all peace and kumbaya and
everything had like healed of illnesses
and whatnot and the Gower's the family
that lived like in the farmhouse kind of
adjacent to the field initially they
were just kind of like Jesus like all
these [ __ ] people like showing up at
this place but then finally they were
just kind of like you know what whatever
it's just we're just gonna let this
become like a pilgrimage site I guess
cuz they couldn't do anything about it
now
had that been all that had happened it
would have just been some weird
hey somebody said they saw the Virgin
Mary somewhere
and then like a bunch of people right
there like trying to get their [ __ ]
diseases healed or whatever but a couple
months later apparently some weird
poltergeist [ __ ] started happening at
the Gower's house as well now one of the
weirdest things that came from rosemary
herself she said that she was cleaning
out this vase like in her house like in
the kitchen or whatever and she had
taken out like it was full of these
dried blue flowers and she took them out
of the vase while she was cleaning it
and she kind of like left them on the
floor and then she went out of the room
for some reason and then she came back
in and she said that the petals had come
off of the flowers and turned into dead
or dying
wasps weird which seems like a weird
type of thing yes awesome yeah I'm drunk
I'm trying to imagine that Jenni's
taking me on a journey I'm taking you on
a journey yeah I'm gonna pair the pair
of paranormal generate journey yeah damn
I came to talk okay I got a snap out of
this [ __ ] I've gotta fight it okay yeah
fight again
oh I'm gonna keep an eye on her too yeah
cuz she's gonna who knows she's gonna
like running for this she's Lena for a
little light she's being relaxed right
now but we don't know what she's gonna
yeah so John Paul the Sun also said that
he had seen um an apparition that he
called the blue lady and he said that he
often saw her standing by the barn he
said it was mother Theresa I don't know
but that's what he's that's who he said
it looked like um there was also and
this is pretty weird too but all the
members of the family said that they saw
this oil stain on the driveway that
appeared on the driveway like like
spontaneously and it looked like an
airplane and this happened right before
Swissair flight 111 crashed in Nova
Scotia
and killed 229 people so they're saying
that [ __ ] is like turning up
that's like predicting the future is
basically what they're saying now just
as in the last case that we talked about
in Pontefract there was also an
apparition of a monk seen several times
in this manifestation as well rosemary
and one of her daughters also said that
she had seen this monk like figure like
walking around the walls and floors of
their house and their barn they also
said they saw that like these weird
stains or like kind of [ __ ] that would
appear on the walls and it looked like a
cross or like like kind of like the
outline of a monk you know what I mean
like the figure of like somebody had
drawn it there or it had like
spontaneously like stained on the wall
or whatever now one of the weirdest
things - and this is something that
comes up in a lot of poltergeist cases
is the old writing on the walls there
have been a couple like when they're
[ __ ] Matthew Manning the poltergeist
boy that had all those [ __ ]
signatures of like famous people like
that would appear on his bedroom walls
and she had appeared while he wasn't in
there so this was another one where
writing was appearing on the walls
allegedly when no one was in the room to
put it there like [ __ ] would appear on
the walls in this case it seemed like it
was always religious type words and
almost always in Welsh even though now
the family were from North Wales now
they said that they could not speak
Welsh which that's probably true because
I think that native Welsh speakers last
time I checked in this was several years
ago maybe two hundred thousand people
they have done a lot in the last few
years at least when I was over there
where they're trying to teach because
most people that live in Wales that you
know their first language is English but
they do teach them Welsh in school
because they don't want the language to
die out
my ex-husband actually he was born in
South Wales
um even though he came from an
english-speaking household neither of
his parents could speak Welsh however
the school that he went to from I
believe the age of five or six until the
age of eleven or twelve was all in Welsh
all of the subjects if you didn't know
how to speak Welsh you were kind of
hosed you just kind of had to listen to
it and figure it out one of the funniest
things was that it's not I guess it's
not that funny but some words for pretty
common things like our concepts and like
math like add and subtract he didn't
know the English words for that he only
knew the Welsh words because that's what
he had learned in school it was all in
Welsh for many years so he didn't know
the English equivalent you know what I
mean but yeah so all of these North
Wales I think has a higher proportion of
native Welsh speakers than South Wales
does but this family in particular said
none of them knew how to speak Welsh I'm
not sure if that's true but there it is
so these words would turn up on the
walls and they said that some of the
most common ones that showed up were
words like and I think I'm pronouncing
this right so please forgive me Welsh
speakers I know there's know a lot of
you out there one of them was a tag Nev
which means peace monic which means monk
go bytes which means hope and Cariad
which means love so these were so this
was kind of like a lovey-dovey
touchy-feely
yeah poltergeist those guys loves you I
guess I'm trying to make peace with you
I guess very suspicious well yeah okay
so the words that first appeared
apparently looked like they were like
stained on the wall like they you know
they were you know of the same surface
like and they looked like they just come
through there later on they look like
they had been carved in you know I mean
so there's two different types of things
that we're looking at here so because
the you know all of the words were like
kind of religious flavored and because a
couple of them had seen like monk like
or you know mother Teresa looking
apparitions or whatever they started
calling
the entity if that's what it was they
started calling it brother dolly which
was short for Adolphus they started
calling it that because apparently some
of the words that were written on the
walls and [ __ ] like that were signed
either Adolphus or Dali like he had
signed it you know what I mean so they
started calling him that
so 1999 because like I said this whole
brouhaha
started in 1997 so two years later in
1999 a bunch of TV programs in the UK
had like featured this case on the show
and then like some weird kind of [ __ ]
started happening where so you know how
like when members of the family would
send emails like to other people
apparently like random Welsh words would
be inserted into their emails and if you
looked at them in the sent folder they
didn't have that but then if you looked
at him like for the Perth the recipients
email it had like all these words like
inserted in there which they said they
did not put in there and like I said the
version in there sent folder evidently
did not have those words there was also
a weird thing where they would they
would print out a document that didn't
have all this stuff in it but when they
printed it out it would have like all
these random Welsh words inserted or
like some of them would be like
upside-down or printed sideways like
along the side of the page you know use
it like that they also said that random
Welsh words would appear carved into the
lawn or like kind of spelled out like in
rocks in the garden kind of [ __ ] like
that so they're like these words are
like appearing everywhere which I think
I mentioned Humpty do before that was
another thing that happened in the
Humpty do case where apparently rocks
would spontaneously assemble themselves
and would like spell words out hmm you
know I mean yeah witch or [ __ ] or would
make shapes like in their driveway and
stuff or on their floor
that sounds like some approach guys
would do yeah and like some of the words
in in the Humpty do case particularly
they were kind of weirded out by them
because some of the words said like Troy
or in fire and stuff like that and one
of their friends had died in a car crash
and the car had caught on fire and the
dew did burn to death
so it was like words that were like
referring to that
right you know I mean which they thought
was very weird that kind of [ __ ] would
happen in poltergeist cases based on my
research although that's not that's not
as weird as they can be sometimes the
words or messages come that say things
no one knows about but later on turned
out to turn out to be Jerry or share and
that that's that's even better yeah well
that's something that you can I mean if
it's properly documented yeah that's
something that if he can prove that
nobody knew that [ __ ] yeah then you
couldn't have like faked it you know
what I mean the thing is those in one
case that came to mind the Warrens were
involved see the lorentz were bad yeah
always a red flag
yeah what was that oh wait she's getting
in front of light she's getting pro she
was like what this yeah but she loves
those lights yeah she like hey she comes
in when they're on she's like she
doesn't care about it she made this in
the damn blue light she's this is so
beautiful kitty loves yeah so yeah
another thing too that was kind of weird
about this was that apparently rosemary
was taking like all these photos around
the property around this time period too
and it kind of showed like a lot of
humanoid figures now there was also some
kind of traditional poltergeist kind of
[ __ ] going on - around the same time
that all these apparitions and all these
words were appearing in [ __ ] you got
you're a poor tations asportation z--
you know stuff would disappear and like
reappear and weird places [ __ ] like that
they had like a lot of unexplained
banging unexplained footsteps voices
they couldn't tell where they were
coming from also a couple people
reported the sound of a baby crying
strange phantom
usually of incense yeah you got some
things got time in the house yeah okay
no [ __ ] odors
well the funniest thing about him is
that she's bringing up my fan of odors
now yeah well because every time every
time you I always know like when I need
to like plug my nose and some [ __ ] over
it because he'll be like damn he goes
damn and I'll be like oh I guess coming
your way
damn at least he warns me what was on
the menu
yeah because sometimes I'll be like oh
it smells just like what we have for
dinner except this and she's ready yeah
everybody farthest yeah but yeah so some
people uh yes it's kind of hard to like
follow up from that yeah but yeah so uh
phantom motors as I said usually incense
or wax which are good odors not farts or
anything uh I'm gonna tell you about
this stuff
what's that I've only worn it run into
one phantom odor okay didn't have
anything to do with the [ __ ] Mountain
poltergeist
but after Mammoth Mountain poltergeist
when I was in Brazil I was [ __ ]
hanging out with a [ __ ] half American
dude named Andrew his dad died in a
[ __ ] big old [ __ ] fire that
happened did it skyscraper in Brazil Sao
Paulo he was the same age as me we must
been around 15th time and I was in his
room with another guy named Nelson
Nelson Augusto was his name which what
happened to Nelson Nelson was crazy [ __ ]
cops killed him later on
yikes yeah kind of an accident that's
when I was in the army cops killed him
Brazilian cops did but he was in a place
we shouldn't have been um going down to
five Ella buying [ __ ] drugs and [ __ ]
down here buy weed and [ __ ] got
caught up in the [ __ ] car oh come on
yeah but the [ __ ] Brazilian cops took
weed real seriously in the favela is
[ __ ] dangerous he went down he went
down there to negotiate with [ __ ]
drug dealers [ __ ] during a time [ __ ]
cops showed up and a gunfight broke out
and he got killed in the [ __ ]
crossfire thanks anyway
we were up in Andrew his [ __ ]
nickname was doodoo we would never say
that in English like smell like doodoo
and we were [ __ ] in his room we were
listening to [ __ ] King Crimson nobody
would think of it exactly were listen to
that damn King Crimson what was the name
of that damn L but it was a red one
no no this is like some Mandy [ __ ] Ron I
think of what name to do with [ __ ]
the psychedelic man [ __ ] Robert Fripp
was playing on and out of nowhere we
smelled the smell of burning candles you
know the wax yeah from burning candles
let that smell
and I was like that smells good these
two dudes freaked out and [ __ ] ran
out and [ __ ] dragged me out of the
room and I didn't know I thought that
meant yeah in Brazilian culture that
that smell is associated with Macumba
because the [ __ ] the candle the
burning candle offerings in the [ __ ]
ammonia and they thought it had
something to do with Andrews dad died
yeah and we went back in there just a
few minutes later and it was [ __ ]
totally totally gone and we have no it
we were in a [ __ ] apartment building
at a 20-story apartment building like on
the eighth floor minute a concrete
without central air Brazil doesn't have
old Brazilian buildings didn't have
central air there no air conditioned
everything's concrete is actually cool
you know if I can know you know that but
[ __ ] a concrete building is cool well
it's because in Florida like a lot of
older houses of concrete but they're so
hot yeah well they're on the ground
because my grandmother's it was concrete
but they're they're low to the ground
yeah and Brazil didn't quite have the
same oppressive humidity as Florida it's
not yeah
but that's a little time I ever [ __ ]
ran into something that may have been a
phantom smell did that come from another
apartment I don't know man it was the
middle of the [ __ ] day that's what I
mean it's like it's really a lot of
these manifestations particularly like
phantom smells it's really hard to
determine because you don't know where
that might be coming from yeah yeah it
could be it was weird like another
apartment yeah it's weird it was weird
it could be coming from another
apartment though it's not that but there
was no central air for it to change air
and it smelled like it was in the damn
room yeah I mean how far does the smell
of a burning candle travel and my
experience it doesn't travel that far
but that was just a weird one of those
endings well it's odd too because um
when we were talking to Steve Mero we
were talking to him about the Rochdale
case and he went into that into the
gardener's house in Rochdale and they
said that they had some phantom smells -
they said they either it was either um
like a cigar smell which they associated
with I think gene was a mom's name or I
can't remember the gene or Jeanine or
something like that but her husband had
died in the house and he had always like
smoked and so she associated like that
kind of tobacco or like whatever smell
with him
they also smelled flowers on a couple of
occasions and they didn't know where
that was coming from whatever this was
it wasn't for me because it didn't ring
any bells I didn't make any associations
to me it just smelled like the smell of
a burning [ __ ] candle you know how
some candles kind of a slight smell like
the red ones yeah it smells okay
that smells good you know I mean and
they were looking at each other and they
whoa whoa and then they freaked out
assessment [ __ ] in Portuguese this
before I was fluent in Portuguese they
started pulling me out of the damn room
we were listening to the [ __ ] we're
like we were smoking weed it's like we
were high yeah but no it was it was real
though yeah I really did smell that but
when we looked around and we couldn't
well smokey
we doesn't make you like just make
things on the whole cloth no hell no and
then I've smoked weed a couple of yeah
and we all agree like [ __ ] candles so
that's what it was yeah ok candle but
that's up yeah that's something they
smelled in this case as well they said
they heard they smelled like um you know
a burning wax type of smell and also
like an incense type of smell ok which
again kind of like goes along with the
whole religious thing yeah well their
reaction was just like theirs they they
associated that with macumba if you guys
don't know Macumba is mokuba's like
cannon bleh
it's a [ __ ] cathodic version of
[ __ ] voodoo and I've been to [ __ ]
Macumba rituals in macumba churches
they're basically Catholic they're kind
of like Africanized Catholic yeah Jules
and the lower working class and the poor
people of [ __ ] Brazil not only do
they go to church they also go to
Macumba rituals but I've been to some of
them they're they're nice they're not
sinister in any [ __ ] way yeah it's
not like the movies no no there it's
just like any other Church but better a
lot of singing and dancing influenced
and if you go a friend a friend of mine
who's a taxi driver took me and because
I wanted to see it and that's where he
went and of course you know I I paid up
to you know I mean I I donated and
everything and watched the [ __ ]
rituals and it's just girls smoking and
they're smoking cigars and dancing and
singing and kind of speaking in tongues
and going it's cold and people are
giving money to the priest and he's
[ __ ] blessing them and or giving
advice and it's it's not sinister in any
way but um the the upper middle class
and the middle class they believe in
that but they don't go to it they're
kind of afraid of it in a certain way so
there's kind of like a class clash
between this stuff well there are some
Macumba rituals that involve putting out
a bowl with maybe like a sacrifice
chicken and some packs of cigarettes and
some candles and you put that out on the
street you can't touch that if you touch
that then it's like
cursed so there's an association with
these burning candles and the smell of
burning candles with if you do the wrong
thing you'll get cursed that was the
Association you know I mean yeah it's
big magic which you know you know which
makes sense right it's very much kind of
like uh Native Americans and [ __ ] I feel
like religious rituals are very similar
all around the world even even from
cultures that didn't like have a lot of
contact yeah previously same thing
people have come up with the same [ __ ]
what I found what I found in you know
living in Brazil and being around that
kind of stuff
I always liked Catholicism didn't really
believe in it but I liked it and I liked
Macumba I like the I thought the African
versions of it were a little bit more
like kind of them like an honest version
of Christian well it's what
down-to-earth he knew what that was
right yeah I mean it was this ISM is
awesome like the iconography awesome but
it always had a thing of like well we
know better than you you're just gonna
impart to you this information whereas
it seemed like a lot of the kind of like
you know voodoo what they would call
voodoo now or macumba or whatever um
that was kind of like the people
retaking or like taking that type of
thing and making it more for a regular
person rather than like this far away
the authority the way I saw was is that
most religions are a veiled way of
paying God to answer a wish or to move
he'll a wish all right I will give God
money or the church money if you'll do
it we do this for me yeah but the thing
is is that Christian churches don't
[ __ ] will never [ __ ] say that all
right
but Macumba will ya Macumba it's very
honest you give an offering and we do
this that's maybe it's very one-to-one
right so it's very honest about it
yeah what which is one of the bit to all
the trappings of communalism and brought
it back down to what it really was level
of like the individual I give God money
and God does something does something
for me
and like heals my relative or whatever
it is yeah so you know I can totally see
that and it's like it's kind of sad the
way that you know religions like you
know what we would call voodoo or vu
d'en if you want to call it that or you
know Macumba haven't been like i feel
like it's been kind of like villainized
in this culture maybe not so much
nowadays but like i remember in the 80s
and stuff like that they did like a
bunch of horror movies well it's
competing with Christianity so they
don't like that make it like Satan
saying it's not though it's not no well
it can be there are Mexican versions
essentially everything person were you
know like something worth a which of
your yes is the Angel of Death and it's
like the drug dealers and kind of like
demon worship but then again you go back
to the Mayans and the Aztecs and what
they were doing was kind of like demon
worship but not really really what it
was and the Catholic priests tried to
explain to the Vatican back in the 1500s
what was going on in Mesoamerica wasn't
that they were worshiping they weren't
worshipping demons they were trying to
buy the demons oh they hate that right
you give something to a demon leaves me
to leave you alone or you give something
to a demon to do something bad to
somebody else which is kind of like
praying for your own success well yeah
you know if I say some [ __ ] is
like [ __ ] with you and right if
you're in a war against another nation
and you're praying for success in battle
right that's the same as praying for the
loss of your enemy so another way to do
that is saying well I'm just gonna hire
a demon to make my enemy loose
yeah so it's a similar very very similar
so it's not evil in that sense it's just
I mean just another just you can look at
things in a bunch of different ways I'm
saying it's from their point of view
it's not evil they're just like hey
we're just trying to help out our guys
yeah
our guys are the good guys and those are
the guys guys and they're the bad guys
right so right so you want the demon to
go [ __ ] up the bad guys and so we will
so I am a lot of the [ __ ] the crazy [ __ ]
you see you know I'm a [ __ ] I'm
talking to my boy comma pops lot out
there you know my Mexican friend down in
[ __ ] TJ all right
because he and I talk about this kind of
stuff [ __ ] privately you know I'm
messenger a lot you know I'm Jo hit my
butt that's my boy he's been with the
show forever
a lot of the stuff that the met the
Aztecs were doing kind of looked evil
until you rationalized it the way that
they did I don't I mean sometimes you
got if if God is creating people and
people are made out of clay and the
blood of the Sun then the more people
are born the more blood is sapped away
from the Sun which can cause [ __ ] to
[ __ ] up so when [ __ ] [ __ ] up the only
thing that that could mean is that the
[ __ ] God is running low on blood oh
[ __ ]
so you gotta get that blood back and
Twitter and tear some hearts out so you
gotta kill some [ __ ] to get God some
of the blood that he's need he's getting
blood starved okay so when you start
looking at it that way and you need God
to keep all the [ __ ] the Sun the moon
in the earth and to keep the corn
growing and to keep the children from
being born
you better [ __ ] cut some hearts out
we're all [ __ ] toast yeah so then
warfare becomes about catching enemy
people from other cities to sacrifice
them and they know what's going on
they're the same religion so it's their
religious duty to walk to the top of
these temples to get their hearts cut
out so their relatives say well God
needs some [ __ ] and their relatives
gotta live you know I mean their
relatives have to live so you can
rationalize all this imagine I often
thought of this can you imagine
believing in that stuff so much you're
willing I will go up to the top of the
thing and I will get my heart cut out
because you think that that will see
your family or you'll that that is
hardcore well you know okay KGB agents
would say that communists believed in
communism so much they'd be spouting off
all kinds of Markus propaganda as thick
as they were being walked to the gallows
to be executed for some break-in some
communist [ __ ] well so that's that same
idea like I said I do even though like
even though like a lot of the um you
know I
I don't believe a lot of like religious
[ __ ] and everything like that but it's
like I do admire people that are willing
to go to their deaths for that [ __ ] they
were giving up their children for it
that's what I mean well that's not cool
because they were doing that to kids
didn't have any choice but they gave up
but if you give up your own [ __ ] for
that they gave up children to keep the
rain falling okay because like I don't I
don't like that because they're like
involving somebody that doesn't but
that's what they did because yeah
Americans thinking rain worse tears of
the gods okay so when you sacrificed a
child the parents would cry and God
would cry which so yeah you could keep
the rain coming yeah and that would make
the corn grow which like I said if you
look at it that way it makes sense yeah
it's [ __ ] up it's it's magic as
sympathetic magic yeah that's what
they're talking well and you have to
think to that I mean for thousands of
years that's how people survived magical
thinking that's why it's so hard to get
rid of nowadays sadly yeah now that we
don't really need it anymore um but for
a long time that kept our s is alive you
know what I mean yeah it bums me out
that like people still believe in it now
but it's like you can understand why it
persists it makes sense when you look at
it that way well yeah that's what I'm
saying so they weren't they weren't
crazy it's just that they're not crazy
at all yeah and like if you can like
look at it from
their point of view and like how they
saw the world and how they saw like
everything that was going on it makes
total sense okay Catholic friars
would try to reason with Mexican you
know Mexican American Mexican Americans
Mexican Indians nothing a Mayans and
Aztecs the Aztecs were just at one
capital city but then you know they were
all Mayans going all the way down to
Central America they would try to reason
with them and try to reason with them to
talk them out of this but a lot of their
beliefs you know they were reporting
back to the Vatican says their beliefs
were equally as strong as Christian
beliefs yeah that they had to do this to
keep the Sun the Moon the Stars it's
very funny to me that like time running
and to [ __ ] keep corn growing and to
keep rain following and to keep God
alive because god of course every time a
person was born small amount of blood
was taken from God yeah to make that
person new person so basically when
they're talking I was overpopulation
yeah yeah I managed so they had they
were trying to be green I guess you
could say in many ways they're trying
there's too many people then crops won't
grow and starvation will happen and it's
so what you're talking about is like
they understood that [ __ ] thousand today
are very close like what you would call
a green movement in a way or a green
ideas the funny thing to me was that a
lot of the the Europeans that overtook
the American continent they had their
own beliefs and for a time I feel like
they they thought that the beliefs of
the natives that were here were beneath
them a bit but the beliefs were very
similar and I feel like not a lot of
them caught on to that well would depend
on who you talking about now we're going
back in time you did some of them did
get it the Spaniards [ __ ] that we're
there in Mexico were they knew that the
[ __ ] Aztecs and I mind were fearsome
they also knew that in many ways
they were ahead because they had they
had cities bigger than they had gigantic
cities gigantic cities number
well-painted there's a bunch of [ __ ]
that people don't realize these were not
primitive people they were just another
not many they were they had a lot they
had whole libraries and a whole
different schools of thought they were
just another civilization they were in
more advanced to save the Japanese you
know I mean these [ __ ] were bet they
they were no joke
it's just that what they were doing was
in direct opposition to what Christians
believed was right like child and human
sacrifice you know I mean there was also
cannibalism going on see how that stuff
it even today you'd be like man you
can't you can't do that yeah man you
can't do that
so I mean I'm not averse to like eating
someone that's already died if you're
like in a situation part of the human
sacrifice was about eating the body part
of the human sacrifice was the body's
leftover alleviated the hunger because
there was ecological problems sure they
were sacrificing people because the food
yields were declining because the soil
was becoming depleted so it was a lot of
it had to do with religion and
desperation okay but there was a
religious explanation for what was going
on
still they just didn't know about
fertilizer that was the real problem
have they had been fertilized and
rotating crops they wouldn't have that
but you see their religions and their
technology didn't have it well rotating
crops is not super obvious not obvious I
will concede so uh you know I'm not
gonna [ __ ] on people for not figuring
that out because I would you know but
that's what I mean it's not as super
obvious how would you know about
fertilization how would you know how
would you know about fertilization right
you just wouldn't know that was
something Europeans kind of stumbled
into over time I think by trial I mean
you can look back at people now and say
like well why didn't it is and the other
but like you know we're coming from the
21st century we know everything are the
other are you think we're going down
another path but on the other hand in
the north in general
most of the time and I've said this many
times on the show it looked like the
white man had nothing but just a
man-crush for the Indians here in the
north and a lot of the things that the
Indians do were what did were
incorporated into the American
civilization well as I said lot of
things about our government the Native
Americans had been here for thousands of
years and they had they had been living
in tandem with this environment for
thousands of years they kind of knew how
the [ __ ] worked well nothing is those
you're talking about things like tribal
governments tribal governments had
councils and they had a bunch of things
like and a lot of that stuff ended up
being incorporated into American systems
of government it got kinda said like you
know what these tribal councils are a
lot like Athenian democracies you know
this is kind of a good idea how they're
doing and you know there are meet there
there was some these Native American
values were kind of became incorp
the white man absorbed them like item of
speech and [ __ ] like that they had that
in in tribal councils the freedom to
bear arms that's all tribal [ __ ] and and
it worked out for them during the
revolutions so you know the United
States has [ __ ] had a lot of Indian
influence on it especially back in the
16 to 1700s
just a very complicated yeah it's
complicated all right it's great to get
back to this ownership so yeah where was
that I'm just I must say the Native
Americans a lot of them we owe them a
debt cuz yeah they're their cultural
influence on us actually helped you
noisiest become a superpower it did yeah
honestly and you know some of the first
American armies and I can prove this
[ __ ] some of the first American armies
in the 1800s [ __ ] you know a lot of
them had [ __ ] huge levels of American
Indian men servant in them in fact even
to the day I was in when I was in the
service back in the 90s if you went by
ethnic group the guys who joined the
most were Indians there weren't that
many Indians it's just that most Indians
joined
same thing as Islanders you know [ __ ]
Micronesians Hawaiians Samoans they
[ __ ] join it's because they're
warrior cultures yeah a man's either got
to be a hunter or a warrior and if he's
both that see that's great
and the only way you can do that
nowadays by joining an army yeah you
know so you know I served with a lot of
Micronesians and a lot of Islanders you
know and and Indians too but I think you
know and I could show you videos of it
going by ethnic group Indian men have
the highest rate of service out of any
ethnic group yeah I buy it yeah
please don't walk okay don't walk on a
keyboard I'll walk on the keyboard she
she largely knows better cuz she kind of
like thinks about it and then she's like
no I find it yeah you know relax yeah
all right so as we went off on what
phantom smells fantastic Baggins I
started talking about farting yeah yeah
[Laughter]
so yeah so they had like the phantom
smells was which was usually incense or
wax as you said they had cold spots
they had a sudden appearance of puddles
of water just as it in the previous case
a weird electrical anomalies which
something very common in poltergeist
cases flickering lights clocks running
slowly phone calls being made from the
house when no one was home interestingly
so in late 2000 Michael Gower the dead
he contacts a parapsychologist doctor
Michael Daniels
he's from the SPR the Society for
psychical research and he comes to the
house several times over the next few
months
well there's Pookie's but yeah [ __ ]
and everything into camera before she's
like give a [ __ ] about that yeah she
said classic she doesn't know about
cameras or bottles or audiences
but yeah so the parapsychologist comes
to the house now he concludes he's there
for several months like he's he didn't
stay there like the whole time but he
was kind of like there like four days at
a time like over a several month period
now he said that in his opinion that
some of the [ __ ] was genuine some of it
was faked or some of it was like a
combination of both things now a couple
of the questionable aspects of the case
that he brought up one of it do you hear
Joshi word yeah that's her standing in
front of the lights she makes this noise
it's like it's like purring but she
doesn't open her mouth and she like
makes it it's almost it's like a whir
and it's like it means different things
depending on the context she told me to
[ __ ] off yeah that was definitely a [ __ ]
off yeah sometimes if you touch her when
she's not expecting it she makes that
noise just like stop dodging me yeah so
one of the things that's a did the
parapsychologist pointed out was that
even though Rosemary Gower had said that
she didn't really know a lot about the
paranormal before all of this [ __ ]
happened he delved into the history and
found out that actually rosemary was
super into the paranormal man and
actually when she was a kid she had been
the focus of a poltergeist outbreak in
her home when she was a child and to
such an extent that she had named the
poltergeist that [ __ ] with her when
she was a kid okay a bit Kelly alright
and she said that it did all kind of
[ __ ] like move should around in her
house and [ __ ] like that what she's
grown up so and then he pointed out the
parapsychologist that after all of this
brother dolly stuff had happened at her
house that she was an artist and she
started an art business where she was
like
selling prints of her art and whatever
and she had called her business in mana
which means the the monk in Welsh so he
thought that was kind of interesting
also he noted this parapsychologist that
some of the stained words on the walls
were misspelled in a very particular
manner that was unlikely for a native
Welsh speaker to make because they were
asserting that the spirit quote-unquote
that was writing these words on the
walls was a native Welsh speaker I mean
you would think that this was like some
monk from like in he spoke wash or
whatever so they're saying that the
spelling mistakes on here was something
that someone that had grown up speaking
wash would not have made like that's all
he was asserting um so he thought that
was kind of suspicious he also said that
some of the words cuz like I said
initially a lot of the words that had
allegedly appeared in the walls looked
like they were like stained but then
some of the later ones looked like they
were carved and he said now so the later
ones that look that had been carved he
said when he went back because he went
back over several you know over a time
period like over settled you know months
he said that some of the ones had been
carved when he went back it looked like
some of them had been like kind of
filled in hmm with like [ __ ] spackle
weird and so he was wondering if the
family had not like carved them
themselves and then like trying to fill
them in to look like they were fading
out because some of the initial ones
that were stained had kind of like faded
over time so he was kind of wondering if
they were trying to like replicate so
he's not saying they were all faked he
was just saying that like maybe they
were trying to replicate some of the
ones that have been stained earlier on
that had faded and then these later ones
that were carved or maybe fake
and then when he went back later they
look like he they had tried to like fill
them in so it looked like they had faded
as well do you know I'm saying allegedly
allegedly that's that's what I'm saying
but that's what he said he said it kind
of looked like that so he thought it was
kind of a little bit suspicious um so
there were also some photographs that
you know the photographs that rosemary
had taken of these um kind of like weird
figures and [ __ ] like that that were in
Windows now he asked to see the
negatives and she said that she didn't
have them um he did get one negative for
one particular very famous photograph
which was like like this kind of white
face that was looking out of a mirror in
the house however when he looked at the
negative he thought that it looked like
the face had maybe been painted on the
glass or smeared on there with lotion he
wasn't entirely sure he couldn't say
like definitively but he said that it
that it would have been that that it
could have been that okay now there was
another thing too is that the
parapsychologists they set up cameras
around the house to see if they could
capture any of this anomalous you know
phenomena now they were left running
pretty much all the time while the
cameras are running no words appeared on
the walls or symbols or anything like
that
now when one word appeared on the wall
during the time that the cameras are
running coincidentally the cameras had
been turned off now when the
parapsychologist asked the gower family
about this they said oh yeah well the
power went out for two minutes that's
what they said yeah do the circuit
breaker two minutes
now later on when the parapsychology is
investigated he found that the camera
that you know the camera in question had
actually been off for two hours [ __ ] and
that when the camera was turned back on
it looked like its position had been
moved slightly yeah so she can re go on
yeah he's so he's not really sure he's
like I'm not saying what's baking yeah I
was baking but they turned that [ __ ] off
at the [ __ ] breaker went in there and
did some stuff move the council yeah
well because the only thing that
happened it was like a cross like Jonah
the wall the camera was plugged into the
wall evidently or two had battery you
don't know okay I'm not sure but he just
said the camera was off and he was able
to determine that even though the family
had said that it was off for two hours
to two minutes it was actually off for
two hours yeah they're gonna claim like
coincidentally during the time that this
cross supposedly appear on the wall okay
yeah um and like I said it looked like
the camera had been moved like the
position had been moved slightly much
like when Pookie moves the argument with
her but as she does when she lays down
by it now the camera also happened to
catch some rather odd behavior by the
son John Paul who was their adopted son
like I said he also had Down syndrome
now on multiple occasions the camera had
actually captured him wearing like a
hooded coat or jacket or something like
that and he would like put the hood over
it and he would like stand by the wall
and like wave his arms at the wall right
in a very weird sort of way right now
later when they would when they would
look at the videos they would see like
these welsh words or the crosses or
whatever like appearing on the walls
coincidentally right where he had been
waving um and on a couple of occasions
they did see that the kid had some
charcoal in his hand I think I would
have thrown this case out by this time
now it should be noted though that some
of the words that were on the wall prior
to the parapsychologist coming there
looked like they had been
into the wall like not drawn on the wall
and some of the ones were like that were
carved on there those ones he kind of
felt like were may be faked because
there there were some tools in the house
that could have been used to engender
those things however some of the [ __ ]
that was it wasn't charcoal though like
some of the earlier ones it looked like
he'd been stained into the wall like it
was like you know put on the walls like
inside the wall it wasn't like drawn on
there you know I'm saying right but some
of the later ones he did think were
faked now they did think that the kid
was maybe doing this [ __ ] because they
said well you know sometimes the kids
left alone in the house and it does seem
like some [ __ ] appears when he's there
or whatever um but he did note as I just
mentioned that when he got to the house
and he examined the words that had that
were already in the walls they looked
like they had been like soaked into the
plaster and when he tried to like rub
them off or like bleach them away or
whatever it they couldn't he couldn't do
it you know what I mean
so he's not saying that like all of it
was faked he's just saying that maybe
has happened in Enfield that um you know
maybe some of the early phenomena were
genuine but then once they brought in a
parapsychologist like after the [ __ ] had
stopped happening someone was trying to
like make something for him to examine
so maybe some of the leadership was fake
I don't buy because some of that [ __ ]
does happen yeah happen sometimes but
not to that extent
yeah I you know I'm not sure about this
case like I said yeah so yeah so he also
said that a lot of the earlier [ __ ] that
he looked at um you know as I said that
looked like it was like staying to the
wall we're also at places that would
have been difficult for a person to get
to it was like like you know behind the
water heater for example or like other
things like that where somebody wouldn't
be able to like necessarily get to
easily whereas the later manifestations
which were scratched or like looked like
they were drawn on were where
someone would could could easily get to
them and could put them in the walls
like a screwdriver or some type of other
tool I invited it if you got a good
phenomenon it speaks for itself you
don't have to focus yeah just wanders a
little bit like I said it seemed like
from 97 to 2000 - it seemed like this
was like kind of a big deal and then it
kind of like faded out and maybe that
maybe that's why maybe that's because
there wasn't a lot of going on now when
the parapsychology was at the house he
did note a few strange anomalous things
that he couldn't really explain he said
that his camera case disappeared at some
point and he and it came up like it
turned up somewhere else which he
thought was very strange you know when
he couldn't really explain it um he also
got a couple of the weird emails with
like all these weird Welsh words in them
and that he said that when he got it
that he had been with Rose Marie Gower
who had supposedly sent the email but
she was not sending it at the time like
the time that it got to him was not the
time that she would have sent it like
they were together at the time and she
wasn't at the computer you know
everything yeah so it's like so he
thought that was kind of weird and had
like all these like weird Welsh words
and [ __ ] which she said she didn't put
in there um he said that he also had
some of the he experienced some of the
phantom smells like he went in one of
the bedrooms and he said there was a
very powerful smell of incense and he
could not find a source for it he also
said that he saw a couple of ambiguous
object displacements like while he was
there like things disappearing and
turning over to other places that he
could not explain although he said you
know yeah it's possible that like some
other remember the family could have
done it but it seemed very unlikely so
it does seem like he he kind of thought
some of the [ __ ] was genuine but that
some of it was fake to try yeah he's not
like saying that it was faked but he's
like it's possible that it could have
been faked now he did say that he took a
picture of a section of wall and there
was nothing there when he took the
photograph but when he developed the
photograph there was like a monk like an
outline of a monk type thing on the wall
like in the photograph which he said
that he had not seen when he
photographed it
now after his investigation ended he
stayed in contact for them now in
February of 2001 very famously rosemary
told him that brother doli her brother
dolly their monk apparition or whatever
it was told them that he was going away
because John Paul the son was too old
now because he was turning 16 hmm that's
what he said that's some weird [ __ ] yeah
it almost sounds like a real case but
yeah this I'm just ambivalent about this
one it's just kind of like I just I I
wanted to add this one because I said
well it's in the UK it's kind of a
famous case it's one that gets brought
up a lot and there was one in the UK
that maybe maybe some you British people
[ __ ] might might remember this one I
think it happened in that early 70s
maybe the 60s it's about a guy teenage
kid he lived above a pub and everything
there was a disturbance going on in his
apartment with his parents and he could
stay in bed and behind him his [ __ ]
cane would [ __ ] do a dance hi born
funny thing about it though and people
would come up from the pub at all hours
of the night to see this poltergeist to
this little [ __ ] tap dance with a
[ __ ] cane could they like yeah yeah
yeah I knew what answer I would answer
out in taps and he'd had both hands
visible the kid so they were they
checked him he wasn't doing it but I
don't remember what the name that case
was I'd like to find it again I couldn't
you know what I remember seeing
photographs
and white photographs of it and well I
remember when I was working on the book
and you told me about that case and I
did like a google search and I could not
find anything it would sit a Kade he had
a cane I don't know if he walked with a
cane or was a cane just a cane in his
house like his granddad's cane I think
he lived with his grandparents if I
remember correctly and he put that cane
on the headboard behind him and it was
started tapping out answers and doing
little dances and stuff and they could
never figure out how he was doing it
they thought he was doing it but they
couldn't see how could have been
imagined and it would answer questions
that he couldn't have known stuff like
that and that correctly see that the
first thing I would yeah it has
something yeah he would add they would
ask the people from the pub would ask
these [ __ ] bizarre ask questions that
there was an answer to but there's no
way he could have known and I don't
remember the name of that case but I'd
like to find it yeah it was in a book I
couldn't find it he was in a book I mean
I had these things called books they
were made out of papers on people don't
use them anymore but it was in a book I
don't remember what that case was maybe
somebody in England fine I'm just saying
like I googled it and I couldn't find
anything which which doesn't mean that
it doesn't exist it's just a lot of
sense no one has digitized yeah there's
a lot of stuff that didn't get digitized
yeah I mean there's there's people out
there doing it like Project Gutenberg
and all them they're trying to like
digitize and I don't want to say that
the case was real I want him to look at
it again because I hadn't read it since
I was a teenager and I've looked at look
I'd like to look at it a little more
closely because man I used to love all
this books and I was yeah when I was a
teenager I used to go to the library I
mean like I had read all the horror [ __ ]
and then like I would go to the
paranormal section I would read all that
I've read all William rolls books all
hans bender all that stuff but like
parapsychology stuff I read all it yeah
like I said I was from that era I
probably only believed about 5% of it
nowadays but it's like Sebastian I was
buying that [ __ ] back then I was by
magic well it's easy to make up these
stories there was
time in which these stories sold sure
you could make money on them you can't
really make money on this especially in
the 70s because I feel like there was
only committed a movie well yeah because
look at like a medieval and all that
which I think was largely [ __ ] and
there was copycats right well I saw the
real thing you've seen the real thing
it's out there it's just that for every
for every fit every every 20 fake cases
there's only one real one and it's hard
time you know if you're not there that's
what I mean and it's hard to determine
which one is because everybody that's
faking it has seen the same movies and
they know that it works and [ __ ] like
that that we have and know about all the
cases that we know about so it's kind of
like they know what to do yeah they was
a fake right so that's what I'm saying
about this one it's like so apparently
after 2001 now I should say that this
might be a point in this case is favor
because you'd think that if they wanted
to make money off this [ __ ] then they
would have continued it and said yeah
the ghost is still here and they would
like start like they'd open a gift shop
and [ __ ] like that but no they said that
the ship mostly left like brother dolly
the monk he's supposedly left in 2001
because he thought the kid was too old
now now the family did say that they saw
some like you know some manifestations
later but it was like much diminished
they said they saw a few apparitions
like a little boy a pregnant girl [ __ ]
like that but it wasn't like anything to
the extent that it was at the time when
it was at its height so you do have to
give them credit in that regard that
they weren't like trying to make a
[ __ ] franchise out of this [ __ ] and
they weren't like trying to like sell
books and gifts and all kind of other
[ __ ] about this brother dolly monk they
basically said well he's gone now so and
I don't think they live there anymore so
I don't think they're still trying to
like you know live off of this legend so
I don't know maybe they did have some
weird like anomalous [ __ ] happen at this
place
who knows
I don't know but I don't know I'm
skeptical of all this kind of [ __ ] so
take that with a grain of salt well I'm
you know I've seen the [ __ ] and I'm
skeptical too most of the cases saying
you have to be because like I said
there's so many fake ones very easy to
fake it right is the problem it's easy
to fake it and there's like a million
other things that it could be other than
supernatural like guys want to see what
a real ones like [ __ ] buy this house
is haunted by click I Lyon Playfair and
I'm gonna tell you you [ __ ] mind
[ __ ] mouth Mountain poltergeist
change solder she's got it on her site
well because that's the way really
that's the way they really think about
poltergeist cases and ones that I wrote
about that seemed legit were that they
don't as I said they don't mean anything
they don't up to anything applaud
they're just very random it's just like
all this dumb random [ __ ] no there are a
couple weeks and then it stops now this
house was haunted by Gaia Lyon Playfair
it talks about you know the Enfield case
he's very honest with it he will say
what he saw yeah and what he trusted and
then he says this is what this person
said and I'm not sure if that actually
happened or not and some of the
phenomena that was reported I don't
think it happened I don't think Janet
was seen from the street at her room
flevit levitating through that I don't
believe that um she evidently was found
in bed with a book and the book came
from next door she said she fell through
the wall and saw the book and brought it
back man I'm almost believing that
because I've seen in my case uh ports
airports in other words an object from
another room appear in your room can a
person do that maybe when a poltergeist
event is going on maybe she could tell
it for
I'm on the [ __ ] fence with that but
that book did come from next door
true the people that lived over there
said that came from over there
so they don't know how she got it she
said she was in bed and she was taken
through the wall saw the room next door
saw the book and grabbed it and then
came back over
that's a [ __ ] bizarre but that's a
UFO style technology if you know what I
just thought of I thought of the first
Nightmare on Elm Street where Nancy
grabbed Freddie's hat and brought it out
of the dream yeah that's what I thought
of but that movie hadn't come out for
several years but that's in that so
after the MPAA's happen that's in that
book only Janet said that now Janet was
speaking with a voice do it through her
mouth but the voice was mostly nonsense
I think it was more like kinda like the
subconscious doing caught her or her
unconscious doing like a Tourette's type
syndrome it claimed to be a dead guy
that once lived there I don't think so I
think she had somehow through
extrasensory perception or somehow she
knew about what had happened there in
the past and was a part of her brain was
mimicking a guy who wants to live there
but when that guy spoke there wasn't any
depth to that personality it knew some
detail just swore mostly just swore he
knew a few details and that's about it
was it that the ghost of that person I
doubt it I don't know that it also barks
and [ __ ] like that dog sounds would come
out of her I think it's something more
like Tourette's yeah more like I kind of
feel like I'm not saying that she did it
on purpose all exactly but I think was
on the other hand I don't think that
dude was still haunting know it either I
think she was kind of semi in a trance a
little bit doing turn she was picking
some shitty stuff up out of the blast
and from the past maybe through like an
ESP and Connor
bring him some information of from the
past or maybe she had heard who lived
there in the past
yeah and forgotten about it or it wasn't
really a lie it was just something she
had picked up over the years yes that
seems yes that's right but the moving
objects was real and [ __ ] the cops
saw it the [ __ ] you know the the
newspaper people saw the Legos flying
around and that's the kind of stuff I
saw and the out ports and and we'll call
it a nap or taking a sport Asians
leaving or it's coming things being
thrown that's really basically just
something disappearing from one location
and appearing in another location
without like a front from an maybe likin
from like an untrained observer in a way
the poltergeist focus or the person
that's causing this this [ __ ] weird
[ __ ] phenomena to happen you could
interpret it as something maybe it looks
like possession and I think a lot of
possession cases are also poltergeist
the kid that inspired the Exorcist story
Roland oh yeah one of the Ronnie Manheim
and one of the assistants to the priest
wrote a book about what he saw and he
said well looking back on it it was
poltergeist yeah he didn't think it was
a demon I put it in my book as well as
the poulterer's yes they said he said
you know and this is back in the sixties
other he he said it fit and you can find
you can find whoa
some you can find interviews with him
yeah he thought it was so the guy should
happen in that case where it's kind of
like the kid was staying at the dudes
house it's like [ __ ] the chair was
vibrating like yeah they had lift up
right like a [ __ ] rug like pulled
under the bed [ __ ] like that he said the
kid COS sent could know things that were
not possible for the kid to know drawers
could open and and the kid was
restrained yeah did we just do it on its
own that's poltergeist yeah Dara's PK
but as I said
you know if you're looking at it in that
content in a religious contest you go
the devil's in them you know a demon
just like the extras yeah but then we
got a good movie out of it you know yeah
but the you know the assistant to the
what was his name Roland what
Roland oh well that's not his real name
but that's what they call them there was
one guy that was an assistant to the
Exorcist he was he was actually just
like an altar boy or virgin yeah he had
like a bunch of students yeah he was
like a priest in training and he had
said it scared the SH out of him but
that looking back on it it didn't he
didn't think it was a demon he thought
it was poltergeist yeah
and that having the 40s nineteen forty
nine forty nine yeah you can find
interviews with him
yeah I wrote about that too but well
cause like I said a lot of the
manifestations seem like that oh there's
cat but yeah what is that what the anus
in the [ __ ] camera why are you being
this way
turn around yeah everybody yeah could we
see your face and say your butt all cats
use ass to greet you I guess
Oh baby all right the show down all
right so all right we are gonna wrap up
this show about various poltergeist
cases hope you have enjoyed its a little
more light heart at least we're not
talking about [ __ ] murderers and [ __ ]
like that yeah although we'll get back
to that next week it's gonna be really
depressing you guys I'm already telling
you right now but yeah so remember if
you liked the show
like share subscribe and all your social
media if you'd like to financially
support the show as many people have
done this week which I really appreciate
because man everybody's locked down
everything's out of work and people are
still giving us money they're loving on
us that just that loving us my cockles
like share subscribe how are you right
now your cockles yeah what the hell is
that that's what my porno movie is
called yeah yes if you'd like to
financially support show you can go to
our patreon page patreon.com/lenguin
i also
a blog called 13 o'clock podcast
wordpress.com and there's a button in
the sidebar that goes to a PayPal
account that goes right to me if you'd
like to give you some money to
contribute for we just bought some new
lights we didn't yeah got you more
coming to ya we've got two more lights
background we're gonna like do some pink
lights on here to make it look prettier
and yeah [ __ ] but yes oh so that'll do
it for episode 194 we'll see you next
time bye
[Music]
you
[Music]